Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Übrigens mal bei äh Taylor Swift nachgefragt, ob sie im Geheimdienstskandal oder bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung vermitteln kann, dann geht da wahrscheinlich noch was.
Also ich verzichte ja gerne auf eine vermeintliche Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn wir dadurch Taylor Swift glücklich machen.
Hallihallo, hier ist das Lokbuch, Netzpolitik, Ausgabe neunhundert, hundertvierundvierzig, live aus der Meta-Ebene, na, nicht live, aber,
Aufgenommen in der Mieterebene nach, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Sendungen, die wir jetzt nicht äh uns gegenseitig in unsere schönen Augen schauen konnten.
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich wann ich das letzte Mal hier war. Hast du, ist es das Regal neu? Das ist neu, ne? Ja, siehst du?
Das Neue.
Seit wann hängt das da? Mindestens so lange war ich nicht mehr hier. Und hier der diese App, dieses Plakat, oh, das ist aber das darf man ja gar nicht sagen, wen du da jetzt gerade von der Wand genommen und durch äh jemand anderen ersetzt hast.
Ich weiß, wer der vorherigen, wo jetzt Alfred Hitchcock hängt.
Ne, der hängt jetzt hier. Der hängt noch. Der hängt nur woanders. Darfst beides sagen. Ja.
Sagen, wer der andere war? Ja, war Holland. Wow Holland wurde hier durch ein äh Alfred Hitchcock Plakat ersetzt.
Ich sage aber jetzt nicht, von welcher Firma das.
Das merkt keiner.
Tue ich vorher nicht an. Ein Wau hat eine, einen besseren Platz äh neben der Kaffeemaschine bekommen.
Kaffeemaschine habe ich weggeschmissen.
Richtig so. Da ist jetzt wow.
Genau.
Und was haben wir hier noch anders? Äh nur sonst alles gleich.
Das Studio wird überarbeitet, aber durch meine fortgesetzte Abwesenheit im äh Geheimdienstausland kann ich äh hier nicht so viel Arbeit reinstecken, wie ich vielleicht gerne machen wollen würde.
Ich verzichte ja gerne auf eine vermeintliche Metaebene, wenn ich dafür ins Ausland kann.
So, wirklich, ja? Mhm. Na ja, das habe ich gehört.
Der Tisch ist auch neu, ne?
Nein.
Aber dieses äh dieses Regal, wo der wo der Bildschirm draufsteht.
Nein. Dir ist nicht so viel neu, wie du denkst. Es ist immer noch die gute, alte Metaebene, wie man sie kennt aus.
Hier haben wir früher immer gepodcastet ne.
Aus historischen Filmen kennt. Ja, aber vielleicht sollten wir dann doch mal lieber
auf unsere äh Themen äh zu sprechen kommen, von denen es wieder so einige äh gegeben hat. Das ist eine ganze Menge
passiert, nicht äh unbedingt jetzt äh viel dabei, was uns in Jubelstürmer aus äh brechen lassen würde, aber das kennt ihr ja schon, ne.
Haben wir denn ähm haben wir denn irgendwelches Feedback zur letzten Sendung bekommen, was vielleicht noch äh erwähnt werden sollte?
Wir haben von jemandem, der es weiß, gehört, dass wer also für diesen, ich hatte ja,
vermutet, dass man im Bundestag nicht so einfach an die IT darf wenn man,
nicht irgendwie eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung hinter sich hat und da wurde uns das Feedback gegeben, wer im Bundestag für diesen Dienstleister, der da die IT macht tätig ist, braucht eine erweiterte Sicherheitsüberprüfung nach Paragraph neun SÜG,
Sicherheitsüberprüfungsgesetz würde ich jetzt vermuten. Und äh da wird uns kolportiert, dass das mehrere tausend Euro kostet.
Diese hinter sich zu bringen.
Nur was teuer ist, ist auch gut. So ist es.
Wer billig kauft, kauft zweimal.
Ja, ihr merkt schon, an Plattitüden sind wir heute äh nicht arm.
Aber die anderen ja auch nicht.
Wie Herr Herr Gal zum Beispiel, der ja nun schon ein paar Mal hier äh erwähnt wurde ohne seinen Namen zu nennen.
Reinhold Geil.
Das ist auch so ein Mensch, den ich bisher noch überhaupt nicht auf dem Zeiger hatte, aber offensichtlich ist er Minister.
Innenminister von Baden-Württemberg, oder?
Ja und der bewirbt sich offensichtlich auch, äh wie.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Äh.
Wie Sigmar Gabriel bewirbt er sich auch für so eine Ehrenloge äh bei der CDU.
Ja, aber ich muss jetzt ganz kurz gucken, ob der das ob der wirklich, ich glaube, das ist totaler äh Unsinn, dass der Innenminister von äh Baden-Württemberg wäre.
Seit Mai zweitausendelf ist er der Innenminister des Landes Baden-Württemberg.
Ich war jetzt sehr erschrocken, weil.
Im Rahmen der äh rot-grünen Koalition, die Baden-Württemberg in bester linker Manier, führt.
Ja. Hier twittert SPD Landtagsabgeordneter Reinhold Wahlkreis Neckarsulm. Heißt das Neckarsulm oder Neckarsulm?
Das weiß ich auch immer nicht so richtig, dass äh hätte ich gerne umschifft diese Frage. Ich befürchte, es heißt Neckarsulm.
Ja, okay, alles klar, aber der ist mir auch eigentlich völlig egal.
Fluss heißt ja Neckar und Sulm ist wahrscheinlich so wie Neckarsteinach und so, da gibt's ganz viele Orte, die so heißen. Also ich würde jetzt mal auf Neckarsulm tippen und Leute, die es besser wissen, können ja in den Kommentaren dann auf mich eindreschen.
Ja, also er er gab auf jeden Fall kurz nach der äh Entscheidung des SPD Parteikonvents, die wir mit seinem Tweet jetzt vorwegnehmen, äh bekannt, dass er
gerne auf Moment, dass ich ich weiß gar nicht, darf man das überhaupt sagen? Also es also er twitterte, ich muss ja hier kurz den Link öffnen.
Verzichtet gerne auf seine vermeindlichen Freiheitsrechte.
Ich verzichte gerne auf vermeintliche Freiheitsrechte, wenn wir einen Kinderschänder überführen.
Ja, da muss man schon echt mal durchatmen, ne?
Also Sozialdemokraten, ne, vermeintliche Freiheitsrechte,
auf die er hier verzichtet, wenn wir einen Kinderschänder überführen, also Kinderschänder ist ja sowieso ähm,
ein Begriff, der ähm eigentlich bei der NPD zu verordnen ist, ne,
Also das ist ein Nazibegriff, der insbesondere geprägt wurde durch diese
Heckscheibenaufkleber die man immer sieht wenn man zu nah an den östlichen Rand Berlins gerät wo dann so in auf den Heckscheiben steht Todesstrafe für Kinderschänder,
Weil das ja eine der größten Sorgen im in äh in in Ostdeutschland ist, ähm direkt äh,
nach den äh Geflüchteten, die dort äh Asyl suchen, sind ja Kinderschänder, die große Plage in Ostdeutschland, äh gegen die sich dann die NPD da richtet.
Und äh mit ihnen dann eben auch Reinhold Gall, der äh also auf seine vermeintlichen Freiheitsrechte verzichten möchte, äh,
um selbige zu überführen. Rede ist natürlich von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
ich würde dann eher so sagen, ich verzichte gerne auf eine vermeintliche Sozialdemokratie, wenn wir einen Reinhold Gall verhindern, äh das verzichten und vermeintlich war dann auch auf Twitter,
noch einige Zeit nehmen.
Das hält sich auch noch eine Weile.
Zeitweise twitterte sehr schön Einigkeit und Recht und vermeintliche Freiheit, fand ich auch sehr gelungen.
Ja.
Auf den Punkt.
Er hat dann aber nachher noch eine Richtigstellung getwittert, meinte es nämlich gar nicht so.
Oh. Ach so, na dann.
Sorry, wollte sagen, dass Vorzeitenspeicherung nur ein vermeintlicher neuer Eingriff in Freiheitsrechte ist. Telekom und Co dürfen ja schon speichern.
Ja, solche Leute haben, mit solchen Leuten haben wir es da zu tun, die ja dann am zwanzigsten Juni wie von uns auch äh angekündigt, ihren Partei begangen haben,
bei dem dann das Ergebnis hundertvierundzwanzig Stimmen für und achtundachtzig Ablehnung bei sieben Enthaltungen zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung gefallen ist.
Im Vorfeld hatte äh Sigmar Gabriel dann diese Entscheidung verbunden,
Mit seiner SPD Führung. Also er hat gesagt,
Auch das hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung schon angekündigt. Die große Gelegenheit der Sozialdemokraten zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe zu schlagen, haben sie da verstreichen lassen, denn sie hätten mit nur einem,
Ja, äh mit nur einem Nein. Ähm,
Sowohl Sigmar Gabriel als auch die Vorortsdatenspeicherung loswerden können. Das ist eine Gelegenheit, die sich nur selten bietet. Die haben die äh Leute da verstreichen lassen.
Aber die Nuss, du bist achtest ja vollständig, was hier auf dem Spiel stand.
Stand das höchste das höchste Gut, das höchste Gut im politischen System und damit natürlich auch das höchste Gut für unsere gesamte Gesellschaft stand auf dem Spiel. Die Regierungsfähigkeit.
Das wäre natürlich schade, wenn du.
Ein schönes Wort, finde ich. Regierungsfähigkeit. Das ist irgendwie auch so ein merkwürdiger Kampfbegriff, der dann immer so hervorgehoben wird, wenn man eigentlich so ja, okay, wir wissen, dass es nicht richtig ist.
Aber äh in unserem äh Fehler in Fieselschweif steht drin, dass man das so machen muss, wenn man eine Regierung ist.
Es heißt im Prinzip, wenn wir diese Scheiße nicht bauen, nehmen wir uns die Möglichkeit, noch mehr Scheiße zu bauen. Das heißt das oder nicht?
Das heißt das oder die? In etwa.
Aber interessant ist natürlich, also erstmal wird gesagt, dass diese,
achtundachtzig zu hundertvierundzwanzig ein ein wird von Sozialdemokraten als ähm.
Quasi,
sehr schlechtes Ergebnis bewertet, also diejenigen, die zu den achtundachtzig Ablehnungen gehören, also die Ablehnungen sind ja dann immer von Delegierten, ne. Es gibt ja noch noch noch gibt's ein bisschen mehr als ähm,
zweihundertzwölf Sozialdemokraten, auch wenn die Prognosen nicht mehr so lange sind, bis sie bei dieser Anzahl von Mitgliedern sind, die die der Trend geht ja stark nach unten, die musst du dir mal angucken, hast du dir mal die Mitgliederentwicklung der SPD angeschaut?
Nicht jüngst, aber es ist auf jeden Fall kein Aufwärtstrend.
Also solange die Aktien nicht so so schnell fallen, äh ist ist alles sicher. Ähm,
Nein, aber da wird also von denjenigen, die gegen diesen äh,
Vorratsdatenspeicherungsbeschluss gekämpft haben, wird dieses Ergebnis im Prinzip schon als äh Ohrfeige für Gabriel äh und besonders gutes Ergebnis in ihrem Sinne,
wahrgenommen,
Interessant ist das dann, Berichte hoch kamen, wie äh es denn da so aussah und äh die Luisa Boss hat einen äh sehr interessanten Bericht darüber geschrieben.
Wo sie also sagt, mindestens in mindestens einem,
Landesverband, hätte die Höhe des Zuschusses der Bundes-SPD für die nächsten Landtagswahlkämpfe zur Diskussion gestanden. Da bist du also als als Landesverband Vertreter,
und dann sagt ihr jemand, ja wir finanzieren ja schon durchaus euren Landtagswahlkampf mit als Bundes-SPD.
Und das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel schade, wenn wir das Geld nicht mehr hätten.
Schönen Etat haben sie da.
Sagt sie, in manchen Landesverbänden, ich zitiere, wurden Delegierte zu Einzelgesprächen mit Prominenten Vertreterinnen der Parteiführung oder der jeweiligen Landes SPD gebeten.
In denen auch ihre persönliche Zukunft in der SPD diskutiert wurde.
Ah, das ist schon echt richtig hart.
Sie sagt, mir sind einige begegnet, die explizit froh waren, dass sie die Freiheit genießen, nichts mehr werden zu wollen.
Und dann sagt sie, das sagt sie, dass sehr, sehr Wichtige, was,
sich jeder, jedes Mitglied dieser Partei durchlesen sollte und hinter die Ohren schreiben sollte. Es ist wichtig,
Diesmal auszudiskutieren, denn wenn wir nur Menschen in dieser
wenn nur Menschen in dieser Partei was werden dürfen, die im Zweifelsfall eine sehr flexible Meinung haben, dann brauchen wir auch nie wieder darüber zu diskutieren, warum wir an Glaubwürdigkeit verlieren.
Amen.
So war der Beschluss und dann war klar, dass äh natürlich die Bundesregierung,
Nach diesem Jahr der SPD auch jetzt möglichst schnell die Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh besiegeln möchte. Vier Tage später sprach dann Bundesinnenminister Thomas de Maizire ähm,
davon, dass er jetzt die Einbrecherbanden künftig mit Hilfe der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh.
An ihrem, an ihrer Tätigkeit hindern möchte,
Denn es geht ja äh die äh Vorratseinspeichung ist ja nur bei äh schweren Verbrechen ähm,
zugelassen beziehungsweise der Zugriff auf die Vorratsdaten ist nur beim Verdacht oder zur Aufklärung von äh schweren Verbrechen,
zugelassenes ist also Mord, Totschlag, Vergewaltigung, Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie, Menschenhandel und die Bildung krimineller oder terroristischer Vereinigungen und,
Wohnung bei ne, die Wohnungseinbrüche in Deutschland, das sind ja alles äh kriminelle Vereinigungen, nämlich bundesweit operierende Einbrecherbanden.
Deswegen Vorzeitenspeicherung. Ansonsten sagt er dann auch, ja das ganz neue, der ganz neue heiße Shit ist ja das predictive policing.
Also die äh vorhersagende Polizeiarbeit.
Die jetzt irgendwo schon getestet wird, keine Ahnung womit, wo man sagt, aus den Einbruchsmustern sollen Prognosen erstellt werden, wo denn wohl als nächstes mit Einbrüchen zu rechnen ist und da soll dann mehr äh Polizei rumfahren.
Wir werden versuchen vor die Welle der Kriminalität zu kommen. Diese ganze predictive Policing Geschichte ist ähm.
Das ist ein Traum, ne.
Na ja, da da genau, das ist ja ein Traum, spätestens seit wie heißt dieser Film.
Ich hab's befürchtet.
Oder so, ne? Heißt ja nicht so.
Nein, ich will auch immer Mission Impossible sagen und das ist es auch nicht.
Identity.
Nein. Oh Gott, Witz.
Ich habe das alles nicht gesehen.
Wir warten jetzt ganz tief im Morast. Ich werde versuchen, das rauszufinden, damit wir noch ein, ein, ein, ein Funken Glaubwürdigkeit äh bewahren.
Okay, das dann damit man denkt, wir hätten noch Zeit, irgendwie Fernsehen zu gucken in unserer Freizeit. Ähm der, also es geht darum, zu überlegen.
Und das ist ja erstmal auch nicht blöd.
Report.
Report, okay. Da gibt's auch mehrere von oder gibt's da auch nur einen von.
Wär mir neu.
Okay. Ähm da geht's darum zu überlegen, okay, man könnte ja einfach mal die,
Macht der Statistik anwenden, um zu gucken, ob sich nicht eventuell Vorhersagen,
treffen lassen. Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn irgendwo ein Wohnungseinbruch stattfindet, jetzt als Beispiel, dann schreibst du irgendwie Uhrzeit auf und äh und irgendwie,
was weiß ich, die Geokoordinaten und sagst irgendwie, was weiß ich, Stadtbundesland, Uhrzeit und so weiter. Und dann könnte es ja irgendwie sein, dass du irgendwann feststellst, dass zu bestimmten Uhrzeiten,
Vermehrt in Wohnungen eingebrochen wird. Ja? Zum Beispiel könntest du feststellen, dass in in Berlin vermehrt zu Uhrzeiten eingebrochen wird,
zu denen die Menschen bei der Arbeit sind. Also Wohnungseinbrüche geschehen nicht nachts, sondern die geschehen tagsüber, weil nachts sind die Leute zu Hause, tagsüber nicht, also kriegst du kurz die Tür ein, marschiert's rein, holst die kleinen
konzentriert konzentrierten Gegenstände raus, ne, wo auf wo viel Geld in wenig ähm Material ist, also um euren,
Müsst ihr euch Sorgen machen um die iPads, ja? Laptops, Walkman, nee, I-Pad, iPod, iPot.
Alles wo Apple draufsteht.
Alter alles veräpple draufsteht außer halt euer Eichener Wandschrank der wird halt dann eben der der wird dann doch da gelassen ne,
Und dann könnt ihr dieses Predictive Policing nach längerer Analyse als zum Beispiel auf die Idee kommen zu sagen, ah den nächsten Einbruch äh prognostizieren wir für,
Berlin tagsüber. Und dann würde die Polizei da mehr fahren oder ihr könntet zu dem Schluss kommen,
In den Gegenden mit geringerem Einkommen äh prognostizieren wir die nächste Schlägerei oder was auch immer, ja? Und ähm der statistische die statistische Herangehensweise, die die man da,
Prinzip nutzt ist, man hat ja dann quasi im Lenkschnitt die Daten, ne, hast du halt über ein Jahr gesammelt und versuchst du einfach, was weiß ich,
der einen Woche irgendwie auf die nächste zu schließen oder vom einen Monat auf den nächsten oder Muster zu erkennen, dass halt irgendwie im Sommer mehr eingebrochen wird als im Winter oder sonstige Geschichten und dementsprechend ähm kannst du dann deine Polizei äh anotieren.
Gar nichts dagegen, auch mit den äh Methoden der Statistik äh Verbrechensbekämpfung zu äh planen, zu optimieren. Aber das ist ja nicht das, was irgendwie mit diesem predictive Policing äh direkt gemeint.
Der soll's noch, da soll's natürlich noch sehr viel weitergehen. Ähm das halte ich aber dann für eher erstmal,
unrealistisch. Aber was übrigens passiert, wenn die Polizei dann entsprechend anziert wird, ist das natürlich dann, wenn weniger Polizei auf den Straßen ist, ähm mehr passiert. Also ich,
Das habe ich schon vor wirklich vor fünfzehn Jahren schon von Polizisten erzählt bekommen, dass sie sagen, ja was weiß ich zu der und der Uhrzeit hat der äh,
Chef festgestellt, da passiert nichts. Da bewachen wir, was weiß ich, eine mittlere äh Großstadt.
Mit äh mit zehn Prozent der Kapazität, weil nix passiert und innerhalb von wenigen Monaten ist natürlich dann genau zu der Uhrzeit die Hölle los. Also das ist doch totaler Unsinn. Die wollen das halt irgendwie besser machen und was sie natürlich.
Unter dem Stichwort Predictive Policing verstehen es natürlich ha,
Prognosen waren bis, haben bisher nicht vernünftig funktioniert, weil wir ja gar nicht genug Heu hatten, um die Nadel zu finden und jetzt machen wir Big Data.
Was ja der Filmreport in den Mittelpunkt äh stellt dabei die eigentliche Dystopie, die damit verbunden ist, ist ja dieses.
Wir wissen ja, dass du das vorhast, weil unsere Daten sagen das ja
Ja? Wir wissen, du wirst einen Mord begehen. Wir wissen, du wirst dieses und jenes machen. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieser Traum, ja, dass man sozusagen das böse TM schon äh aus den Daten herauslesen kann. Im Prinzip äh die Leute schon äh
Tja, was auch immer man dann mit ihnen äh tun möchte, ja? Äh äh bevor sie sozusagen überhaupt irgendwas tun können.
Also müsste ich, wäre ich noch in der Situation, dass ich irgendwie meine statistische Analysefähigkeit verkaufen müsste, dann würde ich auch so etwas bewerben. Aber da ich ja einige Jahre Erfahrung in diesem Bereich habe, halte ich das,
ganz ernsthaft für den absoluten Unsinn,
Also da ernsthafte Vorhersagen zu treffen, das wird sehr schwierig. Selbst mit all diesen Daten, die sie jetzt sammeln wollen. Ich glaube, dass die einfache Ausrede oder eine der vielen ähm.
Eines der vielen Baswords, mit denen jetzt eine.
Ja und vor allem was,
was was ist dann mit unseren vermeintlichen äh Freiheitsrechten, die ja irgendwie sagen, du musst ja überhaupt erstmal was gemacht haben, bevor man dir irgendwas zu Last legen kann, ja? Das ist ja im Prinzip so äh auch die Umkehrung, das
Beweisschlusses, so nach dem Motto, ja, wie, du kannst uns nicht ausreichend belegen, dass du das nicht vorhattest. Aber unsere Computer,
Ja, wir wissen ja, Zuverlässigkeit von Software und so weiter, ist ja unangenehm zweifelt, äh sagen, ja, dass dass du jetzt äh drauf und dran warst.
In dieses Haus einzubrechen.
Also ich glaube, da sind sie noch ein bisschen.
Ja
Davon sind sie noch ein bisschen entfernt, aber das ist natürlich so ein bisschen das, was sie versuchen.
Ja, also ich glaube, das einzige, was.
Da geht die Reise auf jeden Fall hin.
Ich glaube, das einzige, was hier wirklich Predictive äh ist und weil der Terminologie zu bleiben, ist das Verhalten der äh SPD,
In diesem äh ganzen Zusammenhang und na ja, wir sind uns jetzt, wir sind jetzt wenig äh überrascht. Man kann das jetzt noch irgendwie als eine besondere Leistung hinstellen, dass er immerhin achtundachtzig auch mal dagegen waren,
Also nicht nur dagegen waren, sondern auch als Delegierte dafür, also dagegen gestimmt haben,
Das hilft natürlich äh herzlich wenig in diesem Zusammenhang. Wir sind jetzt nicht äh überrascht. Die Art und Weise, wie da parteiintern vorgegangen wird, finde ich extrem bedenklich.
Das sind einfach Methoden, die mögen vielleicht ähm,
Ist jetzt auch nicht überraschend, dass es sowas gibt oder schon mal gegeben hat, aber es macht's einfach nicht okay. Es äh hier wird einfach mal Druck ausgeübt im,
in den Diktat der Regierungsfähigkeit. Und da frage ich mich halt auch wirklich was ist das bitte für ein Begriff? Regierungsfähigkeit.
Das ist in überhaupt, dass du in so eine Partei eintrittst, ja. Und dann kommt da irgendwann einer und will mit dir über deine Zukunft in der Partei reden. Ja, also ich meine.
Ne? Ich meine, sowas erwartest du vielleicht bei äh was weiß ich,
Irgendwie bei der, bei der Deutschen Bank arbeitest, ja? Und dann auf einmal sagst, äh so jetzt hier aber Kommunismus, ne, dann könnte das natürlich sein, dass äh jedem, dass dein Vorgesetzter zu dir sagt und sagt, kommt und sagt, du wir müssen da mal,
Deine berufliche Zukunft hier in diesem Unternehmen sprechen. Wir sind eine Bank. So, ne. Da da gehst du aber natürlich auch nicht hin,
um da irgendwie am.
Heiligen Brauchtum der Demokratie mitzuwirken. Um Geld zu verdienen. Da kann auch jemand zu dir kommen und sagen, hier so und so,
Wenn du hier bei uns mitmachen willst, dann musst du dir musst du dich an bestimmte Regeln halten. Aber in so einer Partei.
Die irgendwie als komisches Sammelbecken für ihrem Gewissen äh verpflichtete Parlamentarier irgendwie dient, ja?
Da würde ich mir sowas sehr verbieten und da würde ich aber auch jeden einzelnen dieser Delegierten, die dazu Einzelgesprächen gebeten wurden,
und jeden einzelnen dieser Landes oder diesen Mindest jeden einzelnen dieser mindestens einem Landesverbände.
Den da mit denen über die Höhe ihres Zuschusses zum Landtagswahlkampf diskutiert wurde, würde ich da aber bitten.
Mit sowas an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. Das ist ja, also ich meine, stell dir das mal vor, das ist ja also ne, das ist das ist Erpressung, das ist nichts anderes.
Parteiinterne Demokratie.
Das ist das ist Erpressung. Das nächste anderes.
Ja, das ist vor.
Aber das ist, das du hast natürlich recht, das ist das ist parteitaktisches Verhalten, parteiinterne parteiinternes Finden eines Kompromisses wird das wahrscheinlich genannt werden. Aber spätestens, wenn wir solche Sachen sehen, egal in welchem Bereich,
Wenn wir hier von ihr, wenn wir irgendwie von einer Demokratie hier reden und wir wissen, dass so etwas da passiert und das ist ja nicht das nicht das Einzige, die einzige Blüte, die unsere schöne Demokratie inzwischen treibt, dann müssen wir einfach einsehen, dass da irgendwas massiv,
Ruder geraten ist.
Ja und ich glaube, was passiert vor allem aus dem Ruder geraten, ist es dieses Selbstverständnis, was eine Regierung zu tun hat. Ich meine, in dieser Koalition,
Ja, wird sicherlich eine ganze Menge Handel äh betrieben so, was gibt's mir für meinen Fisch? So ja, äh Frauenrechte hier äh,
Mindestlohn, ja, kriegt er jetzt hier mal alles äh in den Hintern geschoben, weil am Ende checkt uns das Thema eigentlich auch wirklich nicht, aber dafür müsst ihr halt das und das und das. Und das sind Absprachen, die in einem sehr kleinen Kreis
getätigt werden. Und ich glaube, dass diese beschworene Regierungsfähigkeit hier letzten Endes eigentlich nicht heißt, als wir müssen da unsere Zusagen,
in einem kleinen,
Spitzenkreis einhalten und wenn wir das nicht machen, dann verlieren wir da unser Gesicht beziehungsweise äh kriegen unsere Deals nicht mehr durch. Das ist das, was das meint. Aber diesen Begriff, dafür zu verwenden, wenn ich nur sagen,
Liebe SPD,
Es ist keine Regierungsfähigkeit, sondern das ist bestenfalls eine vermeintliche Regierungsfähigkeit, die hier äh entwickelt wird, weil äh,
Mindestens, wir haben da eine andere Forschung davon, was Regierungsfähigkeit heißt, Regierungsfähigkeit heißt meiner Meinung nach eher die richtigen Entscheidungen zu treffen und na ja.
Es, es, also, diese Abwägung von zwei nicht ähm.
Miteinander in Verbindung stehenden Werten. Das ist ja das, was im Prinzip so eine äh woran halt so Koalition ähm kranken. Ähm ich erinnere mich, glaube ich, da ging's um den,
Jugend, Medienschutz, Staatsvertrag, in da ging es um eine Zustimmung im Bundesrat. Das ist lange her, aber da habe ich mit der damals,
in Berlin,
Wohin ging das denn da? Ich weiß, also ist eigentlich auch völlig egal. Ich glaube, es ging um den Jugendmedienschutz Staatsvertrag und da musste, wurde die Linkspartei gezwungen.
Dem zuzustimmen, weil die ihr Koalitionspartner, die SPD,
Ihnen pass auf, recht äh Sozialstaatliche ähm.
Zugeständnisse gemacht hat. Also die SPD, ne, ist ja jetzt keine Partei, die irgendwie für Sozialstaat oder sowas stimmt. Die hat dann also,
Im Koalitionsvertrag Zugeständnisse an,
Die Linkspartei gemacht, was irgendwie äh bestimmte Regelungen in Sozialstaat anging und oben,
nicht die ganze Geschichte in einem Koalitionsbruch enden zu lassen, war dann die Linkspartei gezwungen zu diesem Jugendmedienschutz Staatsvertrag zuzustimmen. Ähm.
Das denke ich, das ist im Prinzip sowieso schon das Grundübel, ja, dass also ähm Koalitionen, diese Kuh, diese,
Da liegen ja zwei Dinge auf der Waagschale, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Da kannst du halt nicht irgendwie äh die kannst du eigentlich nicht miteinander vergleichen. Und das Maß,
Wurde sie am Ende irgendwie auf eine Ebene bringst, ist dann eben diese Regierungsfähigkeit. Das ist sowieso schon mal eines der der Grundprobleme, weil du möchtest ja nicht, dass deine Parlamentarier zum Beispiel über einen Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag entscheiden.
Weil grade die Konstellation aus irgendwelchen Gründen so ist, dass man sie an den Eiern hat für irgendwelche Fragen im Sozialstaat, ja, das ist ja ein da werden ja zwei absolut unrelate Topics.
Zusammengeworfen. Und das hat man sehr, sehr häufig. Das finde ich schon mal, das ist Ebene eins, das ist ein Problem,
Das ist aber leider in der Ausgestaltung des Systems im Moment so und da werden wir leider ähm.
So in naher Zukunft wahrscheinlich nichts dran ändern, das ist sowieso schon mal ein inhärent irgendwie Demokratie schädliches Ding und das ist auch in keinem Grundgesetz und in keiner Demokratie-Theorie wirklich so vorgesehen,
dass so die Entscheidungsfindung stattfindet, aber das ist eben in der äh real existierenden parlamentarischen Demokratie ähm eines der Phänomene, die wir da sehen. Ich finde aber, wenn,
dann so wirklich individuelle Erpressungen stattfinden, dann ist das nochmal eine Nummer schärfer.
Ja? Ich finde, Gabriel hätte durchaus zu diesem Parteikonvent gehen können und sagen können, Leute.
Ist folgendermaßen. Die haben uns an Eiern, wir haben ein bestimmtes Wahlversprechen, das wollen wir einlösen,
Wahlversprechen werden sie, sie werden uns daran hindern, dieses Wahlversprechen einzulösen.
Also kein Wahlversprechen ist, dass ein Koalitionsversprechen bezieht sich jetzt auf den Koalitionsvertrag?
Oder nein, ich weiß es nämlich nicht, darauf wollte ich nämlich hinaus. Ich weiß nämlich nicht, was es ist, was der Gabriel dafür bekommt. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Vielleicht hat er schon eine ganze Menge bekommen. Ich habe ja ein paar Sachen schon gesagt. Ich meine, in letzter Zeit hat sich die SPD ja am laufenden Meter äh feiern lassen in dieser Koalition. Was sie denn noch nicht alles äh durchgesetzt haben.
Nach Mindestlohn zum Beispiel.
Die ganzen Aktivitäten von Frau Schwesig, Gleichstellung, trallala, pipapo.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob da keinerlei äh Einblick, ob's das jetzt war oder so, aber irgendwie sowas wird es halt gewesen sein
weil das eben einfach auch ein Prozess ist, an äh wie die äh Politik hier gemacht wird, die eben von einem kleinen Kreis geleitet wird,
Und die beiden Dickschiffe da äh CDU und SPD in persona von äh Merkel,
Gabriel Plus eines,
von mir nicht näher definierbaren Entscheiderkreises, der so mehr oder weniger um sie herum äh mehr ändert, die,
Dielen sozusagen, diese Koalition aus. Und am Ende
sind dann sozusagen die Delegierten und die sie vertretenen äh äh Parteimitglieder und am Ende natürlich auch das Volk, irgendwie die gearschten
weil das, was die sich halt im kleinen Kreis mal ausgedacht haben, wie man da die Balance ihrer äh Machtinteressen äh hinbekommt. Da muss dann sozusagen die Realität drauf,
angepasst werden.
Ja irgendwie müssen die sich halt einig werden und das ist halt das, wie sie's äh im Moment tun, ne.
Genau, aber das müsste man schon nochmal überdenken. Ich will jetzt hier nicht komplett äh einerseits in einen Bereich vorstoßen, von dem ich eigentlich nicht viel verstehe, aber ähm,
der auch nicht so äh einfach zu beantworten ist, aber grundsätzlich denke ich, müssen wir mal überlegen, wie wir damit eigentlich als Gesellschaft in Zukunft äh umgehen wollen.
Wir uns in solche Situationen äh begeben wie die, in der wir uns jetzt gerade befinden mit einer Regierung,
achtzig Prozent des Parlaments ausmacht und die vor allem keinerlei Opposition mehr hat. Also das ist ja überhaupt das das Ding ist, die die komplette parlamentarische Arbeit findet mehr oder weniger nur noch,
in diesem Koalitionsgefüge, in diesem sehr kleinen Kreis davon äh statt, weil das, was die Opposition sagt und macht.
Das merkt man ja auch für dich in dieser Legislaturperiode, überhaupt, auch nicht, auch nur im Ansatz, irgendeine Auswirkung. Es ist sozusagen, es findet nicht statt.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt haben wir aber noch ein ein jetzt mischen wir ein bisschen die Phänomene. Ähm das äh koalierende Parteien solche sich im Prinzip auf was weiß ich, Koalitionsverträge einigen,
sagen so, folgendes ist unser Programm und da steht halt drin Vorzeitenspeicherung von mir aus Mindestlohn. Ja, nebenbei ist ja eine gute äh,
Wir haben jetzt im Prinzip eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung bekommen,
So als Preis für Mindestlohn und ähm Gleichstellung. So, das könnte man jetzt nun mal sagen. Was wir aber wahrscheinlich der größere Teil ähm gerne haben möchte,
der wäre wahrscheinlich ein Mindestlohn, eine Gleichstellung und keine Vorzahlenspeicherung, ja? Und.
Diesen Koalitionsvertrag haben dann eben die Parteien geschlossen, die haben in sich intern äh eben diese.
Abwägung der Werte für sich beschlossen und sich darauf geeinigt. So, das Phänomen,
Dass dann diese linientreue verlangt wird, das hast du aber auch,
bei anderen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, ne? Da musst du nicht achtzig Prozent für haben, da reichen dir irgendwie sechzig, da hast du genau das gleiche Phänomen, ne? Dass dann eben der, du hast dann einen starken Koalitionspartner und einen Schwächeren und das dir halt dann ähm,
einander äh ein ein Versuchen, ein ähnliches Maß an Zugeständnissen abzuverlangen, um äh dann so dieses Land in die in die Zukunft zu führen.
Das ist sicherlich richtig, aber ich denke auch, die Situation sehe ganz anders aus in der SPD, wenn es nicht erforderlich wäre, sieben äh Abgeordnete zu überzeugen, für irgendwas zu stimmen, sondern äh vielleicht äh,
Größenordnung von achtzig oder hundert bist dann auch wirklich die Mehrheit der Regierung sozusagen gefunden ist und hier kann man einfach auf eine ganze Menge äh scheißen. Und die, die jetzt hier untergebuttert wurden, die wissen auch, dass dass sie sich sozusagen,
in einer sehr schwachen Situation befinden, weil es sehr, sehr schwierig ist,
überhaupt einen Widerstand in der Regierungsfraktion zu erzeugen.
Richtig, also genau, ich wollte nur diese beiden Probleme mal so.
Auch äh vollkommen klar.
Also Entscheidungsfindung leider nicht immer nur sachbezogen. Das ist eines der der unschönen ähm.
Probleme, die wir haben, kommt aber auch daher, dass man ja, was ja immer die große, große Sorge, die große, große Sorge, äh wenn man sich da äh mal so,
ähm,
Politik theoretische Politikwissenschaftliche Texte zu durchsiehst. Die große, große Sorge ist ja immer, wir könnten Weimarer Verhältnisse haben, wo das Parlament dann nämlich irgendwie zu,
wenig Disziplin und Zwängen unterlag und zu viel debattiert hat, zu wenig gemacht hat, zu wenig Autorität,
vermitteln konnte, zu wenig vermitteln konnte, dass es irgendwie Herr der Sache wäre und was ja dann dazu geführt hat, dass äh man äh,
historisch dann eben davon ausgeht, dass das Volk sich dann eben einen starken ähm,
Führer gewünscht hat, ne. Das heißt, äh es ist auch dem dem Wunsch nach Stabilität geschuldet, dass eben die meisten politischen Debatten, die wir in der Öffentlichkeit wahrnehmen, ähm,
einem klaren äh Ziel zustreben und dass wir ähm.
Vielleicht als Bevölkerung diese Variation in der Debatte, die dann irgendwie was weiß ich so ungefähr fünf Prozent vom Ganzen beträgt, ja, ist der Mindestlohn jetzt so oder so äh oder,
ist der für diese Bevölkerungsgruppen oder nicht. Ähm dass das letztendlich aber alle darüber einig sind, der Mindestlohn wird kommen. Ja und Vorzeitenspeicherung wird kommen.
Dass das nicht davon ausgegangen oder es ist sicherlich auch so, dass das natürlich der insgesamt der Bevölkerung ähm ein ein Gefühl von Sicherheit vermittelt.
Die Regierung ähm vorhersagbar ist, dass man nicht damit rechnen muss, dass sie sich morgen irgendwas grundsätzlich anders überlegen,
vielleicht zum Beispiel die Reichen enteignen oder so, das wäre natürlich eine große Sorge. Nein, aber du, ne, es hat auch damit zu tun, dass man durch diese ähm durch diese.
Umgang mit den Dingen ein eine Stabilität herstellt und,
letztendlich eine Regierbarkeit des Landes und natürlich auch das, was man dann irgendwie Regierungsfähigkeit nennen kann. Das haben wir natürlich immer sehr schade, wenn das dann darin mündet, dass einzelne Personen eben erpresst werden. Ähm,
Ihre berufliche Zukunft. Und da kann man, glaube ich, nicht, ähm, leider,
äh an dieser Stelle jetzt sagen, dass ein Problem der SPD oder dass ein Problem der CDU oder ein Problem der Mehrheitsverhältnisse, das muss man erstmal zur Kenntnis nehmen und sich überlegen, wie man ein System gestalten kann,
in dem möglichst solche Effekte nicht auftreten und man trotzdem eine eine gewisse Stabilität gewährleistet,
die Antwort darauf verraten wir euch ein anderes Mal.
Genau, denn äh wir müssen ja vorher noch äh über Netzneutralität reden. Das ja äh auch wichtig.
Oliver Roaming.
Ist noch viel wichtiger. Roaming ist überhaupt viel wichtiger. Da ist ja Blitzneutralität. Äh weißt du, da denke ich ja gar nicht mehr über Netzneutralität nach, wenn ich über Roaming nachdenke. Habe das Problem ja laufend, ne.
Und Roma,
Rome ich langsam mein Konto ab.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das Robbing-Problem ist eigentlich gelöst, seit man sie einfach im Ausland eine schöne, billige SIM-Karte kauft. Die sind da eh alle billiger. Also mit dieser ganzen Romerei, ja.
Was habe ich davon, wenn ich hier meinen beschissenen Vertrag auch noch in Europa äh im im europäischen Ausland nutzen muss? Bin doch froh,
irgendwo hier aus Deutschland raus bin und da mal ordentlich Gigabytes für ein paar Euro kaufen kann mit einer Prepaidkarte, also im Prinzip diese ganze ist zu meinem Nachteil,
So, ich bin SIM-Karte raus, Freiheit rein oder wie so, ne?
Vermeintliche Freiheit. Weil deine Telefonnummer ist ja weg.
Also denke ich an Netzneutralität, denke ich, an Thomas Lohninger. Der war jetzt ähm zusammen mit Wilhelm Eschweiler, Vizepräsident der Bundesnetzagentur. Bernhard Roleder,
Bernhard Roleder vom IT-Branchenverband Bitcom,
Und Alexander Sander von digitale Gesellschaft EV und Benz Gott von der Stiftung Neue Verantwortung. Ben Scott übrigens sehr interessant, der hat ähm,
Der war in der Netzneutralitätsbewegung in den USA aktiv.
Dann einige Zeit ähm mehrzpolitischer Berater von Hillary Clinton, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Als die Außenministerin war und jetzt ist er irgendwie in Deutschland bei der Stiftung neue Verantwortung,
Und Thomas hat da einen schönen Satz gesagt in dieser Ausschusssitzung die der im Prinzip also ist halt ist wahrscheinlich auch mehrere Sätze aber ist also ein ein Absatz da sagt ja eigentlich alles was zu Netzneutralität zu sagen ist.
Die Reklassifizierung würde es Telekom-Anbietern ermöglichen, einen doppelten Markt zu eröffnen.
Was meinst du jetzt mit Rehklassifizierung?
Ähm dass man also sagt, äh es gibt nicht nur einen Dienst, sondern mehrere Diensteklassen, ja?
Ja.
In welchem Onlinedienstanbieter sich von diesen einen.
Also von den Telekom Anbietern einen bevorzugten Zugang zu deren Kunden kaufen könnten. Damit wäre das zwei Klasseninternet festgeschrieben und das Prinzip der Netzneutralität Geschichte.
Durch einen solchen doppelten Markt wären die Anbieter von Onlinediensten in der Situation
entweder ihre Dienste in minderer Qualität als ihre Konkurrenz anbieten zu müssen oder mit jedem Telekom-Anbieter eigene Verträge über den Zugang zu dessen Kunden,
auszuverhandeln. Und das ist,
einfach der Kern des Problems, hier schön wirtschaftlich ausgedrückt, ja, Wirtschaft ist etwas, was ähm die Leute interessiert. Ähm Hintergrund muss man, glaube ich, auch bei der ganzen Netzneutralitätsdebatte,
sagen. Der Hintergrund ist das Internetanschlüsse wahrscheinlich gerade einfach mal zu billig sind. Ähm das ist noch ein,
ein unschöner Aspekt der ganzen Geschichte, der natürlich auch gegen die Netzneutralität steht, weil die ähm.
Die ähm Telkos, Telekom Anbieter natürlich sagen, okay, zu den Preisen können wir hier nicht gewinnbringend äh unser Kupfer überall in der Erde vergraben, weil sie nicht auf die Idee kommen, einfach mal Glas zu vergraben.
Aber das regelt doch der Markt.
Regelt der Markt, genau und das ist das, da führt's dann eben hin.
So, das war also in der Anhörung im Bundestagsausschuss Digitale Agenda. Wir wissen aber, dass der Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda im Prinzip für nichts federführend ist und einfach da so ein eine Talkshow im Prinzip. Leider.
Gesprächsrunde.
Talkshow ist. Ja,
Aber wichtig, dass es auch mal gesagt wurde, weil da werden ja zum Beispiel Protokolle veröffentlicht beim Bundestagsausschuss, digitale Agenda, im Gegensatz zu anderen Ausschüssen, wie zum Beispiel unter dem Untersuchungsausschuss. Insofern gibt's dann da eine Bundestagsdrucksache und da steht das dann drin.
Und die wird natürlich unter Umständen eventuell herangezogen, wenn man irgendwann dann mal aus den richtigen Ausschüssen eine Legislation äh dem Parlamentariern herabreichen möchte.
Gespräch war letzte Woche am siebzehnten Juni. Das haben wir, glaube ich, noch nicht erwähnt.
Genau. Dann gab's ähm eine sehr schöne.
Studie von Transparency International. Da muss man zu sagen, es gibt eine Selbstverpflichtung der EU-Kommission, nur noch in Brüssel registrierte Lobbyisten zu treffen.
Und es gibt die Absichtserklärung äh diese Termine dann auch zu veröffentlichen.
Das heißt, sie haben sich vorher auch mit Lobbyisten getroffen, die nicht in Brüssel äh registriert sind.
Genau. Das war also das quasi die Transparenz Initiative quasi zu sagen, okay jeder Lobbyist,
der sich mit einem Kommissionsmitglied unterhalten möchte, möge äh ein registrierter Lobbyist sein.
Und die Kommis, die äh Kommissionsmitglieder sind dann eben auch angehalten,
Termine auch zu veröffentlichen, ja? Dadurch entsteht dann ein ein Datensatz, den ähm Transparency International ausgewertet hat und das ist ganz schön.
Gibt dann so Ergebnisse wie fünfundsiebzig Prozent aller Lobby äh treffen, sind mit Firmen oder indusrepräsenterrepräsentanten der Industrie,
Ähm dann haben sie sich auch mal angeschaut, mit welchem Cup, mit welchem Budget,
Die Unternehmen, die dort lobbyieren, ausgestattet sind, das sind bei Microsoft und EXON ExON Mobil äh jeweils viereinhalb Millionen. Deutsche Bank ist irgendwie knapp unter.
Millionen, was Euro im.
Euro. Ja, Europäische Union pro Jahr. Natürlich.
Ja weiß ich nicht, äh pro Monat zahlen, was weiß ich.
Achso, ja, könnte auch pro Monat sein, aber ich gehe mal pro Jahr oder? Warte mal. Ja, jetzt muss ich, da muss ich sogar nochmal gucken. Ich habe jetzt in meiner Naivität, bin ich davon ausgegangen, dass,
sowas irgendwie pro Jahr ist. Kannst du mal auf den Link klicken, dann lösen wir das jetzt mal hier live auf.
Ja, wo ist er denn der Link?
International, etwas ja, zwei Zeilen hoch.
Jo, ja. Ein informierter äh Podcast, Page not found. Äh Moment, sorry.
Habe ich den.
Könnte mein Fehler gewesen sein. Es ist auch mein Fehler. Also eigentlich ist es nicht mein Fehler, aber nein, nur dass ich meinen Workarout nicht äh korrekt angewendet habe, aber hier ähm.
Lobby Budget in Euro.
Sieht hier auch ich. Ja,
genau.
Ja, also diese Lobbyisten, ne, die haben ja dann irgendwie den gibst du ein Diensthandy und einen Dienstwagen und dann ein ein straffes Jahresgehalt,
und ein ordentliches Reisekostenbudget oder eine Wohnung in Brüssel, da kommst du halt mit viereinhalb Millionen kommst du da schon weit, ne? Ich meine, was zahlst du zum Lobbyisten?
Der kostet sich ja vielleicht jetzt irgendwie irgendwas im Bereich hundert, vielleicht hundertfünfzigtausend im Jahr.
Also, ich meine, wenn ich mir so vorstelle, was wir irgendwie aus diesem Podcast machen könnten mit viereinhalb Millionen äh im Jahr, da geht was.
Ja, aber dann immer rumreisen und so. Ja, viereinhalb Millionen ist nicht, ist nicht wenig Geld.
Ich würde mich aufopfern.
Nach Brüssel, ich glaube nicht.
Das ist ja, kriegt er jetzt nicht ein Lobbyist.
Für viereinhalb Millionen okay, also interessant auf jeden Fall mal zu sehen, was es eben kostet,
seine Interessen dort ähm zu vertreten, ne. Das finde ich ganz interessant. Google an sechster Stelle mit dreieinhalb Millionen
Siemens ist da drunter, Huawei hat auch drei Millionen in den Topf geworfen. British Patrill, zweieinhalb Millionen Daimler mit grade mal mickrigen zweien,
zweieinhalb.
Deutsche Bank ist auch mit vier Millionen vertreten. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ganz ordentlich, was da ausgeht.
Ist ein Geschäft. So und da gibt's halt sehr schön, wo sie dann sagen, in welche mit mit welchen ähm Sekt,
Sektoren oder mit welchen Geschäftsbereichen treffen die sich am meisten? Klima und Energie,
vierhundertsiebenundachtzig Meetings haben sie also aus ihren Millionen da gemacht, aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus möchte, ist.
Dass ähm auf diese Zahl mit den fünfundsiebzig Prozent, fünfundsiebzig Prozent Lobby-Meetings mit Firmen und Industrievertretern,
Und insbesondere wird da jetzt kritisiert, unser Herr Günther Oettinger, dem wird nämlich nachgesagt, er habe sich überwiegend von der Seite der Netzbetreiber beraten lassen.
Und,
der äh EU-Abgeordnete Michelle Reimann von den Grünen sagt, wenn Öttinger seine Position bezieht, dann setzt er sich immer für eine konzernfreundliche Lösung ein ähm,
Und Öttinger selbst sagt aber, ja, nee, dieses Lobbyregister spiegelt seine Treffen ja nicht korrekt wieder, denn da muss ja nicht eingetragen werden, wenn er sich in einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung an Bürger wende,
auf einer Konferenz spreche oder Abgeordnete treffe. Richtig, wenn er nämlich auf einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung sich an die Bürger wendet, dann sagt er nämlich, dass die Befürworter der Netznetralität eine Taliban seien. Das steht jetzt quasi in diesem,
Register nicht mit drin, da müssen wir ihm also nochmal einen Punkt für geben, dass er sich mit den Bürgern getroffen hat. Und das Ergebnis.
Was wir also jetzt in Sachen der Netzneutralität gerade sehen. In dieser Woche finden die sogenannten Trilog-Verhandlungen zwischen Parlamentrat und Kommission statt,
Und wir wissen ja, dass das Parlament mit einer sehr starken Pro-Netz-Neutralitäts,
in diese gesamte Angelegenheit reingegangen ist. Wir wissen aber auch im,
in der EU wird ja im Prinzip nichts nach nach Recht und Unrecht entschieden, sondern die Sorge der EU ist ja hauptsächlich, dass.
Märkte harmonisiert werden. Insofern sprechen wir nicht von einer Netzneutralitätsverordnung der EU, sondern von einer Regelung für den elektronischen Binnenmarkt,
Wir erinnern uns, die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie, die die EU hatte,
war ja ebenfalls eine Richtlinie zur Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes, auf das es keine äh wirtschaftlichen,
oder Benachteiligungen der Marktakteure gebe, aufgrund von unterschiedlichen Anforderungen zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ja, also EU ist immer Markt,
Datenschutz wird da nicht diskutiert, weil man Datenschutz haben möchte und weil das wie Peter Schaja in seinem Vortrag beim,
Nee, beim dreißig C drei, glaube ich, sogar, ne?
Weiß gar nicht genau. Äh dreißig C drei glaube ich. So schön betont hat Datenschutz ist ein Menschenrecht. Das wird da nicht diskutiert, weil die EU da sitzt und sagt, jetzt mal hier Menschenrechte harmonisieren. Nein. Das geht ja immer um die Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes und Binnenmarkt heißt dann eben
innerhalb der europäischen Union und ihrer Mitgliedsstaaten. Und da wollen sie eben nicht nur die Netznetralität.
Harmonisieren, sondern auch das Roaming. Und
Da geht's eben darum, dass man sagt, ja, wenn hier, ne, Menschen innerhalb Europas sich bewegen, dann sollen da eben die Roaminggebühren irgendwo gedeckelt werden und dann werden sich natürlich alle
Marktteilnehmer an dem höchsten Wert orientieren und dann haben wir harmonisiertes Roaming.
Und jetzt wird also Roaming und Netzneutralitätsregeln ähm diskutiert. Und da ist also ein Kommissionspapier publik geworden.
Und da fehlt auf einmal die klare Definition der Netzneutralität. Denn der Europäische Rat möchte gerne,
keine großen Hürden dafür haben, ein Zweiklassen jetzt einzuführen, wie es Thomas äh beschrieben hat, ja. Dieser Begriff des Zweiklassennetzes finde ich da ähm.
In zunehmendem Maße irreführend, denn es wird natürlich ein.
Es wird nicht da um Klassen gehen, sondern es wird wirklich um einzelne Deals gehen, wo sich die,
Telkos, den Onlinediensteanbietern als Trolle auf der letzten Meile,
ähm entgegenstellen. Und das wird natürlich umso schöner werden in unserer Zukunft, wenn dem,
Kapitals folgend es immer weniger,
äh Telcos geben wird, weil die sich alle gegenseitig auftauchen, aufkaufen und dann am Ende so ruhende Oligopole sind.
Das möchte der Rat aber ganz gerne,
Schon so haben, dass sie da äh in beide Seiten melken können und deswegen wurde der Absatz gestrichen der gesamte Internetverkehr möge gleich und ohne Diskriminierung, Einschränkung oder Störung, unabhängig von Absender, Empfängerart, Inhaltgerät, Dienst oder Anwendung transportiert werden.
Und da findet sich jetzt nur noch irgendwo unter ferner lief 'nen unter drittens dass diese Regelung für das
offene Internet gelten soll. Ja? Und da haben sie dann wieder, ne, ihre Klassen und so weiter. Weiterhin sagen sie.
Mhm. Ähm.
Die Package Inspection. Klar, das regulieren wir. Das darf nur noch eingesetzt werden, wenn es aus rechtlichen Gründen,
oder für die Netzwerksicherheit nötig ist. Ähm auch Netzsperren, wie die britischen Pornofilter sind natürlich absolut in Ordnung, weil,
siehe aus rechtlichen Gründen stattfinden, nämlich es gibt ein Gesetz, was es verlangt,
Nichts anderes heißt ja, dieses aus rechtlichen Gründen. Und sie sagen, sie wollen also für die Package-Inspection eine
gesetzliche Basis und es darf kein unverhältnismäßiger Grundrechtseinschnitt stattfinden. Das darf sowieso nicht, weil wenn es ein unverhältnismäßiger Grundrechtseinschritt ist, dann wird's eben von einem höheren Gericht kassiert. In dem Fall vom,
EuGH. Ähm insofern könnten sie sich das auch sparen,
Könnten sie auch sagen, kann ruhig unverhältnismäßig sein, nur dann wird ihnen die gesamte Richtlinie wieder eingesackt und eine gesetzliche Basis zu verlangen, ähm heißt in dem Fall, am Ende auch nichts anderes als äh ja, näheres regelt ein Bundesgesetz.
Ja, das ist auch, also das sollte auch jeder
sich nochmal extra klar machen, dass das so in dieser politischen Diskussion immer wieder der Dreh- und Angelpunkt ist. Das wird halt gerne behauptet, man würde sich ja für Netzneutralität einsetzen für das offene Internet, aber dann gibt's ja noch was anderes und das sind ja diese Spezialdienste und das ist ja was ganz anderes, weil das ist ja überhaupt
gar kein richtiges Internet und so und äh äh das ist eigentlich genau der der Dreh- und Angelpunkt, weil in dem Moment, wo man eben,
etwas anderes als das Internet definiert im Kontext von Internet, dann ist es halt kein offenes Internet mehr, sondern es ist eben genau das Gegenteil und das.
Andere Internet.
Das ist für dich also ein neues Sprich äh erster äh Güte und äh hier gilt es natürlich gegenzuhalten.
Beim Roaming hingegen bleiben sie hart, da meinen sie wohl mehr mit Punkten zu können. Also das das äh da wird jetzt harmonisiert im Sinne der Kunden,
Und in einem Interview sagte dann Oettinger, hat dann quasi dieses äh so,
geschildert und sagte so, darauf werden sich EU-Kommissionen, die Regierung der achtundzwanzig Mitgliedsländer und das europäische Palent,
meine Güte, das Europäische Parlament, wahrscheinlich schon sehr bald einigen. Und das ist ja auch wieder so ein sehr schönes Ding, dass dann eben so ein EU-Kommissar hingeht und für die Regierung der achtundzwanzig mindest äh Mitgliedsländer, jetzt bin ich schon bei der mindest,
und das Europäische Parlament und die Kommission spricht, worauf die sich dann sehr bald einigen werden, ne?
Das ist eben diese politische Stabilität und Vorhersagbarkeit, die uns allen äh Sicherheit vermittelt,
Die entscheidende Abstimmung kann tatsächlich schon diese Woche erfolgen. Und jetzt müssen alle auf Save the Internet EU gehen,
und dafür sorgen, dass da die Netzneutralität.
Hast du noch,
im Kopf, wer für das Parlament das verhandelt in diesem Trilog, macht das der Parlamentspräsident, das ist der Schulz selber oder gibt's für die einzelnen,
ähm Gesetzesblöcke da nochmal separat beauftragte. Da bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher.
Bin ich auch nicht, aber ich würde eigentlich vermuten, dass das doch dann immer der Reporteur ist, ne. Der Berichterstatter.
Der Berichterstatter tut das auf jeden Fall innerhalb des,
Parlaments bis es zur Entscheidung des Parlaments kommt. Der Reporter ist ja sozusagen derjenige, der aus dem zugeordneten Ausschuss während diese Initiative des Parlaments beraten wird,
für das Parlament rapportiert.
Ich aber auch.
Die Personen dann aber auch äh quasi an der Front in der Verhandlung mit äh Rat und Kommission stehen, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt selber nicht. Ist ein bisschen doof, müsste ich eigentlich wissen, weiß ich aber jetzt gerade nicht.
Na ja.
Kommen wir nun zu etwas völlig anderen.
Oh ja. Button.
Frankreich ist schockiert. Schockiert. Nein. Doch.
Schockiert. Nein. Doch. Oh. Wirklich?
Denn Wiki Leaks hat NSA-Dokumente veröffentlicht.
Und möchte mit diesen Dokumenten belegen, dass äh US-Spionage gegen die letzten drei französischen Präsidenten stattgefunden hat. Die letzten drei französischen Präsidenten,
Nikola Sarkozy und jetzt Franois.
Es klingt wie ein Gedicht, oder?
Und sie haben noch veröffentlicht mehrere so Zusammenfassungen von ähm Intelligence, also quasi das, was dann der der Analyst hört sich das ja alles an und schreibt dann eben einen Report.
Und da gibt's dann irgendwie so Reports über interne Griechenland-Debatten. Ähm und ein Bericht, in dem geschildert wird, wie sich,
Francois Holland ärgert, dass sein Vorgänger Nikolas Sarkozy ähm es versäumt hat, einen gegenseitigen Spionageverzicht mit den USA zu vereinbaren. Wir kennen das.
Was kein No-Spie-Abkommen?
Und äh da haben sie also ganz, ganz schön einfach mal wieder so interne US-Intelligence äh geleakt und sagen eben, jo ähm.
Das also das ist quasi diese Überwachung nicht nur die Person selber betroffen hätte, sondern eben auch ihre Berater.
Und,
ähm da haben sie dann also selektoren veröffentlicht, ne, wo dann eben sagt, so ja hier der und der wurde äh gesammelt und Berater und so weiter und diese Telefonnummer. Ähm ärgerlicherweise sind es aber wieder keine,
primär quälen, sondern halt so zusammenfassende Übersichten. Und wir erinnern uns, dass daran jetzt das Verfahren wegen der oder die Ermittlungen wegen der
Merkel Überwachung eingestellt wurden, weil das eben äh dem Generalprüfanwalt äh eine einen Grund gegeben hat zu sagen, ja hier, das ist ja kein Beweis,
Ähm.
Auch fragen.
Interessant ist, warum jetzt grade? Und ach so.
Warum was jetzt gerade, warum diese Dokumente veröffentlicht wurden?
Genau, also aber erstmal zu sagen, klar, dann wurde der äh der Botschafter der US-Botschafter wurde dann eben in Paris zum Rapport bestellt. Das ist dann so eine,
Eine krasse, diplomatische Maßnahme, ne? Das passiert selten, dass man dann sagt, so komm jetzt hier her, was ist hier los? Und dann sagt er, ja. Ähm das hat Deutschland auch gemacht,
Als im Oktober zweitausenddreizehn es um das Merkel-Handy ging, ne? Da musste dann der US-Botschafter mal hin zum Rapport,
Äh und wir erinnern uns, was dann am Ende daraus geworden ist. So,
Warum veröffentlicht das genau jetzt gerade? Wir erinnern uns an.
Genau. Und Charlie Epdo wird jetzt grade geerntet. Ähm erweiterte Lauschangriffe, Videoüberwachung,
Staatstrojaner und eine ausgeweitete Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Äh blühen inzwischen aus der Saat des,
Charlie Epto Massakers. Ähm die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Frankreich soll auf bis zu fünf Jahre ausgedehnt werden, der Geheimdienst soll Staatstrojaner verwenden dürfen
um Internettelefonate abhören zu können,
oder heimlich eine Onlinebesuchung durchzuführen und das Ganze ohne richterliche Kontrolle. So will es die,
Französische Nationalversammlung und der Senat, die beiden parlamentarischen Kammern in Frankreich, die jetzt beide ähm eilig für einen Gesetzesentwurf gestimmt haben, in dem die Überwachungsbeflugnisse,
der Behörden ausgeweitet werden sollen.
Und wären quasi in Frankreich diese Überwachung massiv ausgedehnt wird,
Reaktion auf den auf die Attentate oder auf das Attentat.
Veröffentlicht. Jetzt diese Spionageergebnisse gegen die Franzosen,
die französische Regierung, die natürlich jetzt völlig schockiert ist,
dass das stattgefunden hat, ne? Abhören unter Freunden geht ja gar nicht, aber auf die eigene Bevölkerung ist das natürlich was ganz anderes. Und das ist ja auch das, was ich in,
Deutschland denke ich hab das hier in dieser Sendung schon mal erwähnt, bemängle.
Und äh das zeigt äh Wikileaks eben mit dieser Veröffentlichung sehr schön auf. Diese Pikoterie, die da allen Orten anzutreffen ist.
Also dass die Franzosen jetzt ihre Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die sie ja schon längere Zeit haben, jetzt auch noch ausweiten wollen, finde ich ja sehr interessant, alleine in den Zusammenhang, dass ja auch für Frankreich im Prinzip das Urteil des EuGH äh gelten sollte, zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ich frage mich, auf welcher
äh rechtlichen Grundlage, dass hier eigentlich äh noch erfolgen kann. Weil das ist ja nun etwas, was man dann einfach mal locker,
beklagen können sollte.
Da bin ich mir halt nicht so sicher. Also es ist ja erstmal nur die Richtlinie weg. Also da müssten wir, da sollten wir vorsichtig sein.
Ja, also ich zweifle jetzt nicht an, dass das jetzt hier tatsächlich geplant und auch äh äh beschlossen wird. Ich äh freue mich halt nur, ob,
ähm durch den Wegfall der Richtlinie sagen wir mal vor allem den Aussagen des EuGH nicht hier äh auch für ein französisches äh,
Gericht, von dem ich nicht genau weiß, in welcher Form das äh existiert. Da eine Vorlage existieren sollte.
Lassen wir das. Sie verabschieden jetzt erstmal ihr Gesetz und beschweren sich gleichzeitig ähm, dass sie abgehört werden und ich denke, das kann man auch erstmal so stehen lassen.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Tim hat heute ein sehr schönes äh T-Shirt an, wenn ich das mal schildern darf. Da ist das Logo des äh GCH Q an, drauf. Und da steht,
Sehr schön. Finde ich sehr schön.
England gekauft.
Hast du dir in England gekocht?
Vom Guardian.
Solche T-Shirts verkauft hätte Guardian. Das fand ich irgendwie auch gut. Mal gucken, jetzt ist ja der Chef weg. Mal gucken, wie lange sie die Dinger noch verkaufen, aber.
Ist der der Russriger ist weg?
Ja, der ist jetzt äh, weiß nicht, in Rente gegangen, auf jeden.
Hat er nicht noch irgendwo sein? Hatte der nicht irgendein anderes Angebot?
Äh ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nur, das er da jetzt aufgehört hat.
Okay, gut. Aber du willst ja, als er als, als.
Genau, also
Ja genau also der GCHQ, den äh wir alle kennen, das ist so im Prinzip das, was der äh NSA in in seinen Aktivitäten in England am
kommt und die ja auch mit dem NSA ordentlich unter der äh Decke stecken, wieder zahlreiche Veröffentlichungen der letzten zwei Jahre immer wieder gezeigt haben,
die vor allem auch äh erheblich
beteiligt sind bei den Überwachungsmaßnahmen auf den Glasfaserkabeln, von denen nicht wenige über das englische äh oder überhaupt das britische Festland äh laufen auf dem Weg sowohl nach Europa, dem Fest,
Kontinent, wie der Brite sagt, äh und natürlich äh in Richtung USA,
da sind sie auf jeden Fall äh fleißig dabei und die ganzen Veröffentlichungen hatten aber auch eine,
Auswirkungen, nämlich, dass nämlich äh dann doch tatsächlich das Treiben des GCAQ mal genauer untersucht wurde und ähm,
Dazu wurde äh die sogenannte Invest Ticketory Powerstreoner.
PT äh ein Geheimdienstgericht herangezogen und es hat sich sozusagen das Treiben des GCHQ mal äh angeschaut. Das Ganze kam sozusagen in Reaktion auf die ganzen NSA-Veröffentlichungen. Da wollte man dann doch schon mal den Eindruck erwecken
dass man sich doch mal irgendwas genauer anschaut. Und jetzt äh gab's wohl insgesamt auch äh,
drei Urteile und das vorerst letzte äh Urteil ist jetzt gerade äh gefallen,
Wo ähm unter anderem die Überwachung von NGOs in Südafrika und in Ägypten,
genauer unter die Lupe genommen wurde. Konkret waren das in,
Ägypten, die Ägypten, Inisitive for Personal Rights EIPR
eine Gruppe, die sich den persönlichen Rechten äh widmet, sehr interessant. Und zwar äh versuchen sie sozusagen sich explizit um,
-Rechte äh zu konzentrieren, die jetzt sozusagen dem Menschen am nächsten sind,
Das sind dann konkret der Körper, die Privatsphäre und das Eigenheim, das eigene Haus. Und in Südafrika war es.
Vermeintliche Eigenheit.
Mein Südafrika war es eine Gruppe, die nennt sich Legal Ressources äh Center, LAC
wohl die größte äh Anwaltsvereinigung dieser Art äh ist, die sich um Public Interest Law kümmern, also,
in irgendeiner Form öffentliche Angelegenheiten in gesetzlicher Natur, also ein rechtlicher Natur äh untersuchen und die dort ähm ja wohl ein,
Stellenwert hat, darüber weiß ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so viel,
Naja und äh es hat sich wohl ergeben, dass eben der GCHQ auch in diesen Ländern ordentlich dabei war, auch diese Organisationen abzuschnorcheln und,
Na ja, jetzt gab's halt ein ein Urteil, äh eben von diesem IPT, äh was halt dem GCH Fehlverhalten nachwies,
Schon mal ganz interessant, wenn man sich anschaut, was sozusagen jetzt äh das Fehlverhalten ist, äh was hier äh nachgewiesen wurde, nämlich mitnichten,
Tatsache, dass sie einfach mal NGOs überwacht haben, daran hat sich so recht äh wohl keiner gestört, sondern äh im Falle von.
Ich glaub den Ägyptern,
war es die zu lange Speicherung von E-Mails? Nicht die. Nicht dass sie irgendwie eBays überhaupt abgefangen haben und gespeichert haben. So, nein, es war dann einfach äh zu lang. Ich kann's grad nicht weiter äh quantifizieren.
Und ich glaub beim war sowas wie eine unrechtmäßige Begutachtung einzelner Kommunikationsdaten. Also mit an sich also an sich,
sozusagen eine Null-Aussage. Äh äh es wurde halt irgendwas rausgepickt, wo irgendwie so recht kein,
Ja, würde ich sagen. Wo wo irgendein Maß äh überschritten wurde. Und ähm na ja,
das äh ist halt auch alles so ein bisschen absurd in den äh in ähm
Britannien, weil dort halt auch generell die Tätigkeit des GCH halt eigentlich überhaupt nicht angezweifelt wird. Das einzige äh äh was letztlich bemängelt wurde, auch im Hinblick auf die Kooperation mit der NSA im
zum Beispiel mit Prison äh,
dass irgendwie diese ganze Abhörtätigkeit nur so lange als illegal eingestuft wurde, solange es keine einsehbaren Regeln dafür wieder das äh zu erfolgen hatte, äh Vorlagen
und ähm die hat dann eine GC Hedge Crew so äh produziert und gesagt, ja hier, das sind unsere Regeln
Haben alle gesagt, ja okay, alles klar, na dann, dann ist ja gut, dann machen wir weiter und äh.
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen? Also das ist so die Art und Weise.
In Großbritannien, wie man da rechtsstaatlich an die Geheimdienstaktivität heranging. Ich bin übrigens am GCHQ vorbeigefahren, ich war in Seltenham,
Ahnend. Ich hatte das überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig auf dem Zeiger, fuhr aber auf einmal in diesem Ufo vorbei. Also erstmal tauchten überall so Schilder auf, GCAQ, ist sowas wie äh,
gerade eine Demo oder so und fuhr dann irgendwie äh die Straße weiter und dann äh tauchte auf einmal links und dieses doch massive äh massive Gebäude Komplex äh auf.
Ich war nur ein paar Meter weiter auf dem Campingplatz. Nichtsahnend, hatte mir den aber nichts sozusagen danach äh ausgesucht und äh ja, ein äh.
Opulentes äh Gebäude auf jeden Fall
Ja? Ich war dann übrigens auch in auf so einem Science-Festival, wie das äh heißt. Das ist so eine Art Veranstaltung, die gibt's wohl in England häufiger. Dann sicher auch äh ganz, ganz nett. Da war also mit viel Tamtam und Brummborium da auf dem großen Marktplatz.
Aufgebaut worden und in der Stadthalle und so weiter. Überall wurde halt Science berichtet. Es war auch,
interessant, gerade für Kinder und so weiter, also alle äh Arten von wissenschaftlichen Organisationen haben sich dort äh präsentiert und man konnte äh allerlei,
Interessante äh Dinge mit herumexperimentieren und Dinosaurierforschungen und alles, was das Kinderherz äh beglückt, aber auch für die Erwachsenen war was dabei,
und in dieser Stadthalle selbst, die so ein bisschen das Zentrum von dem Ganzen äh Boot waren dann eben noch äh weitere ähm wissenschaftliche Organisationen präsent.
Und der größte Stand war vom. Auf diesem Science Festival,
wo auch viele Kinder rumliefen und auch ähm der GCHQ Stand hatte auch einige interessante Angebote für die jüngsten äh dabei.
Shirt war aber nicht dabei.
Das hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt leider noch nicht.
Weil das wär dann eigentlich elegant gewesen, wenn du dann einfach so einen Stand, dann stellt man sich dabei, ne?
Auf hier würde es Selfie der Woche gewesen, aber das äh.
Einfach so auch dann da Leute mit beraten.
Ja es äh ich war ein bisschen überrascht von der Situation. Ich muss,
als ich nach Zelten hinfuhr, hatte ich GCHQ nicht im Hinterkopf, war dann sehr überrascht, als ich sozusagen sowohl dem Gebäude gegenüber stand als auch Willi später
in dieser Stadthalle mit diesem Buß, wo halt so junge äh Menschen äh mit freundlicher Miene halt irgendwie äh ja und hier und wir beschützen ja äh die Nation und wir sind ja hier gegen Terror.
Und hier guck mal, Glasfaserkabel so.
Doch hier mal ein interessantes Spiel und testet auch mal deine Intelligenz und so weiter. Ich ich muss jetzt mal kurz meine äh, mir fällt das jetzt gerade erst wieder ein. Ich muss mal kurz meine meine Fotos da nochmal durchblättern. Ich hatte da so ein paar ähm,
Fotos gemacht, aber sie hatten halt so Recruitment-Material auch am Start. Also es ging schon auch dadrum.
Hast das nicht mitgenommen.
Wissenschaftler äh doch ich habe.
Aha, wieso hast du denn das mitgenommen?
Ähm weißer Geier, vielleicht strebe ich ja auch noch mal eine äh wissenschaftliche Karriere an, man äh sag niemals nie,
Sag niemals nie.
Du willst ja nur jetzt schon in einem Apple Campus von morgen arbeiten.
Genau,
so nennen sie sich, ja, ja. Ich zeige dir gerade mal hier ein paar Fotos.
Ja, also das ist halt ganz klar und dann konnten die Kinder dann halt auch kleine Soldaten äh Spieler auf dem Bildschirm äh spielen und so. Also da da konnte einem schon so ein bisschen äh äh schlecht werden und ähm,
wurde mir dann auch und dann habe ich's halt irgendwann auch äh ja sein gelassen, weil ich irgendwie keinen Bock hatte,
Kindern dabei zuzuschauen, äh wie sie da aufm Geheimdienst stand, Soldatenspiele spielen,
Der zweitgrößte Stand gehörte dann übrigens ähm Raceion, dem,
Militärindustrie Unternehmen, die hatten da so eine Oculus Rift am Start und so und da. Also.
Tim, aber du musst halt auch so sehen, ne? Ah, ich meine, Bologna und so, ne, wir müssen natürlich auch die Wissenschaft einfach sehr viel näher an äh die Industrie und natürlich auch an den militärisch industriellen Komplex heranbringen, ne.
Ja natürlich, spielerisch äh heranbringen. Es gab dann übrigens äh das hatte ich ja auch noch äh fotografiert auch sehr hübsche. Es gab dann ein ein den sie dann irgendwie an die Wand äh geschraubt hatten. Also.
Aber der ist jetzt nicht vom.
Doch, doch, das war auf dem GCHQ Stand und da stand dann irgendwie Inspiring The NextGeneration of Coders und äh da merkte man schon, in welche Richtung das geht, also sie sind wirklich auf der Suche einfach nach absoluten Informatik, top,
Spezialisten.
Ja mit arbeiten.
Wie gesagt, das ist halt ein Stand gewesen, der sich vor allem an junge.
Also nicht nur, aber viel war dafür für Kinder nicht nur, es war so eine Mischung, ja. Äh es wendete sich halt in gewisser Hinsicht an an alle und ähm.
Haben die eigentlich auch drei D Drucker oder so?
Auf dem Stand hatten, die keinen 3D-Drucker? Nee, aber man hatte schon so ein bisschen den, die waren so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach Thurings einfach.
Könnten wir mal dann auch zum Camp einladen.
Hey, wir haben doch da so einen geilen und so.
Wir wollen da könnt ihr mal ein bisschen rekruten.
Wir müssen mal weitermachen. Das haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt.
Okay, wir müssen mal weitermachen. Aber das finde ich ja echt äh irre, dass äh,
Die Bilder müssen wir, kannst du die noch mit dann in die Shownotes machen vielleicht? Ja, mach mal. Bilder in den Shownots, das ist äh da bleibt einem ja echt die Spucke weg.
Ich habe ja nur so ein Foto von der US äh Military Recruitment-Station, wo Mickey Mouse und so stehen. Kann ich auch nochmal da reinfügen. Ähm.
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, Sitzung am siebzehnten Juni. Da gab's ein sehr äh spannenden Eklat,
denn während die da so ihr ihre Sitzungen saßen.
Wurde dann über die DPA getickert, dass der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss doch bitte,
Eine hochrangige Person aus dem Justizbereich benennen möge.
Mit einem Fragenkatalog ausstatten solle, sodass diese Person dann als selektoren,
beauftragter,
Einsicht in die Selektoren haben können. Und diese Person äh solle dann äh dem,
NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss berichterstatten. Dabei geht es darum, dass es ja einen Beweisantrag des
NSA Untersuchungsausschusses gebe. Ich sage jetzt immer NSA Untersuchungsausschuss ist ja natürlich eigentlich der ähm Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss und der BND Untersuchungsausschuss, der jetzt eben diese selektoren einsehen möchte,
die vom BND verwendet wurden auf Gehalts der NSA. Ähm.
Und es soll eben verhindert werden, dass der parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss ähm,
Als ganzer Einblick in diese NSA ähm selektorenlisten erlangt und.
Es soll ebenfalls in umgangen werden, so Christian Ströbele, der bei uns auch schon zu Gast war, dass der Parlamentarier parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss,
als Auftraggeber einen eigenen förmlichen Ermittlungsbeauftragten zur Sichtung der Listen einsetzt. Denn dessen gesichtetes Material müsse nach dem Gesetz auch allen Ausschussmitgliedern zugänglich sein,
so Christian Ströbel. Ähm,
Diese Aufforderung wurde dann auch noch den Ausschussmitgliedern äh mitgeteilt, aber in einem äh Geheimdokument.
Ist geil.
So, das heißt, die Exekutive will jetzt der Legislative vorschreiben, wie ihr eigener Untersuchungsausschuss, der sich ja im Prinzip gegen die Executui Executive selbst richtet,
wie mit.
Ja genau, also ihr dürft uns ja gerne kontrollieren, aber.
Klären euch wie.
Genau. Hier sind die Regeln.
Und das ist natürlich ähm zurecht von der Opposition als äh Frechheit.
Empfunden worden und wir werden jetzt sehen, wie sie damit umgeht,
innerhalb des äh Untersuchungsausschusses gibt es natürlich dann auch nochmal ähm,
Debatten zwischen den einzelnen Parteien, äh wie sie sich denn diese Einsichtnahme überhaupt vorstellen und so weiter. Ähm Fakt ist, dass äh die amerikanische Partei,
Die ja hier auch die ganze Zeit mitredet, das wollen wir nicht vergessen, äh der Bundesregierung hat verlautbaren lassen, dass ähm sie jedwede Einsichtnahme in diese Selektorenlisten ähm ablehnt,
als Verletzung ihrer Interessen so ungefähr.
Möchten ja jetzt nicht deren Interessen verletzen, nur weil die irgendwie äh ne, das geht ja so nicht. Und äh wir werden sehen, wie sich das äh weiter entwickelt und möchten an dieser Stelle.
Ähm einen Podcast empfehlen, was wir sehr selten.
Warte mal, kurz nochmal zu dieser äh Geschichte, weil gerade was du sagst, so die Amerikaner sitzen mit am Tisch. Das ist ja auch ein Argument, der äh Vertreter der Regierungskoalition gewesen in dieser ganzen Debatte, dass ähm.
Die Amerikaner das nicht wollen.
Denn nicht nur, dass sie es nicht wollen, sondern dass ja die Bundesrepublik mit den USA ein gegenseitiges Abkommen hat darüber, dass sie sich doch gegenseitig ihre geheimdienstlichen Erkenntnisse nicht äh veröffentlichen. Das gelte ja auch genauso in der anderen Richtung,
die Amerikaner, die fangen doch jetzt nicht an, Deutsche äh Geheimdienst ähm Erkenntnisse in irgendwelchen Untersuchungsausschüssen zu präsentieren und äh genauso wenig ähm
dürfte man das ja auch äh hier tun, weil man habe ja diesen äh Vertrag, ja, das äh kann,
Also kann's sogar nachvollziehen. Ja, äh die eigentliche, das eigentliche Problem ist, dass es solche Verträge gibt.
Du musst halt ja auch deine äh Regierungsfähigkeit halt erhalten. Wenn du da Verträge brichst, geht halt leider nicht. Sorry.
Das stimmt, ne? Aber darum dreht sich das im Prinzip, das heißt, die Regierung sagt ja im Prinzip, naja, wir würden euch ja gerne, äh, dabei unterstützen, aber wir können ja nicht, weil ist ja geheim.
Und äh diese diese Idee quasi nochmal zwischen den Untersuchungsausschuss und äh die Exekutive nochmal jemanden äh dazwischen zu äh spannen,
Ich hatte so den Eindruck, dass das wie soll ich sagen, dass es nicht grundsätzlich.
Keine Verständigungsmöglichkeit über so eine Konstruktion gibt, um sozusagen Einblick in das super Geheimnis zu erhalten. Aber die Prämisse, dass dann sozusagen auch noch die Regierung bestimmt oder auch nur,
äh mit absegnet, wer denn das jetzt ist, dass das sozusagen dieser Ausschuss nicht noch selber ähm,
bestimmen kann. Auch das ist nochmal sozusagen ein ein extra Eklat, der hier mit reinkommt.
Na, sie wollen halt vermeiden, dass da irgendwie einer reinmarschiert.
Mit einem fotografischen Gedächtnis sich merkt, welche Firmen da alles auf der Liste standen und dann am nächsten Tag im Untersuchungsausschuss,
Eine Reihe an Firmennamen runterlässt, was ja noch gar nicht so tragisch wäre, weil das ist ja nur öffentlich, wird hier aber nicht dokumentiert. Und dann sitzt halt Andre da, schreibt die Firmennamen mit,
Und dann kann man das bei Netzpolitik Ort nachlesen und dann sind die Amis sauer. Die Firmen vielleicht nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Die sind dann auch sauer, aber halt nicht auf Andre.
Ach so, ja. Aber auf die äh deutsche Bundesregierung.
Sogar doch, vielleicht sogar doch.
Ihr äh weil sie ihr Parlament nicht unter Kontrolle hat. Oh, hm, sollte das nicht eigentlich andersrum sein.
Oje. Aber wir wollten Podcast empfehlen, Pod.
Genau, weil es gibt äh auf jeden Fall eine gute Möglichkeit, sich in diese ganzen einzelnen Aspekte und Abwägungen, die selbst wir nicht äh ausreichend zu beschreiben in der Lage sind, äh sich dem noch weiter zu nähern, als es hier möglich ist.
Weil äh es einen neuen Podcast gibt, ein neues Podcast-Projekt, was äh der Form auch schon vor zwei Jahren hinterstand
können oder vor einem Jahr hätte starten können, aber nicht hat, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es ja auch keine Kritik, sondern sozusagen nur
der Hinweis, dass es das jetzt endlich gibt seit ein paar Ausgaben, nämlich den Podcast technische Aufklärung von
Jonas äh Schönfelder und Felix äh beziehen. Die sich halt tatsächlich die Zeit nehmen,
Untersuchungsausschüssen in voller Länge beizuwohnen,
Und danach auch noch, also währenddessen und danach äh einen Podcast zu produzieren. Natürlich dürfen sie im,
Untersuchungsausschuss selbst keine Aufnahmen machen, ist ja klar, sonst müsste, sonst müsste ja äh auch nicht Andre alles transkribieren, was er da hört.
Mal so ein Mikrofon reinschmuggeln, das sah jetzt echt irgendwie.
Ja, das macht man einmal, ne?
Das macht man einmal und nächstes Mal macht es.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Also äh wie sie's auf jeden Fall machen, ist,
einerseits ähm ihre eigenen Eindrücke äh schildern, so ein bisschen so den Rahmen des Tages äh kommentieren, dann äh teilweise die Mitschnitte der dem Ausschusssitzung folgenden Pressekonferenzen,
äh beifügen, also die ganzen Verlautbarungen der einzelnen äh Fraktionen.
Also nicht alle jetzt unbedingt immer vollständig, aber sozusagen das, was sie als relevant erachten, äh teilweise auch mit äh einzelnen Vertretern noch
Interviews führen und was dann sagen wir mal auch für die Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik am vertrautesten sein dürfte in so einer Abschlussrunde mit ähm verschiedenen Teilnehmern, die ihr auch schon hier äh gehört habt äh sozusagen um eine Bewertung des jeweiligen Tages durchführen. Also es gibt im Prinzip,
Pro Ausschuss Ausschusstag da eine Sendung, so ist es zumindest bisher. Und da könnt ihr dann,
Bekanntschaft schließen wieder mit äh Andre, Meister, Anne Roth war da schon äh dabei, Daniel Lücking.
Wir hier noch nicht hatten, äh kommt dort äh zu Wortjournalist, der auch vom Untersuchungsausschuss eifrig äh berichtet, hier und da äh beim neuen Deutschland, glaube ich, ähm veröffentlicht. Einmal äh die Woche,
und noch einige andere.
Ja und dessen ähm gut gemachter Podcast, kann ich euch alle ans Herz legen, wenn ihr Lust habt, das Geschehen des Untersuchungsausschusses noch weiter tiefer zu verfolgen.
Für uns haben die ja keine Zeit.
Wer jetzt genau alle.
Andre und Anne.
Die sind nämlich bis über beide Ohren voll mit Arbeit von diesem Mist. Ja, Anne klagt äh und oder beschreibt ja, mit wie viel Papier sie da als
Äh Mitarbeiterinnen der,
Fraktion im NSA und der Fraktion die Linke im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss äh zu tun hat und die haben keine Zeit mehr.
Für gar nichts.
Also zumindest nicht, um jetzt hier äh häufiger zu Gast zu sein, als es ohnehin schon äh sind, da wollen wir uns auch gar nicht beschweren. Aber ist natürlich ein gutes Timing, weil äh eben halbübermüdeten Zustand nachdem der Ausschuss ist, setzen sie sich halt nochmal draußen auf die Steine und äh machen dann nochmal eine,
abschließende Beleuchtung des jeweiligen Tages. Ich fand das sehr interessant und man kriegt da eine ganze Menge Details und noch mal mehr so ein Gefühl. Ich ich freue mich übrigens über das Format auch nochmal äh extra, weil es im Prinzip auch so eine Umsetzung,
einer Idee ist, die ich vor ein paar Jahren schon mal hatte mit Philipp. Äh wir hatten also Bundesradio mal vor uns hin konzipiert, da ist da nie was draus geworden, aber damals haben wir im Prinzip genauso diese Idee, mit WG direkt in die Ausschüsse und berichten von da, eher so als
allgemeine äh Begleitung über alles, nicht spezifisch auf einen Untersuchungsausschuss,
in gewisser Hinsicht passt es hier noch sehr viel besser, weil da hat man irgendwie einen klaren Fokus und klarer Fokus ist für einen Podcast äh immer super,
Das ist etwas, was ich finde, was auch andere Untersuchungsausschüsse gebrauchen könnten. Eigentlich müsste jeder Untersuchungsausschuss, den die Bundesrepublik Deutschland so in Zukunft noch produzieren würden. Ich bin mir sicher, da werden wir noch den einen oder anderen haben. Äh.
Ist eine Wachstumsbranche.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine Wachstumsbranche. Und vor allem zeigt sich auch, dass das Format Podcast hier einfach auch geeignet ist,
Dinge auch auch sehr gut abzubilden, wie ich finde.
Das ist ein Audio-Podcast, oder?
Ist ein Audio-Podcast.
Eigentlich ein Video-Podcast vor dem Parlament machen oder müssten Sie da vorher den Architekten fragen.
Das ist eine Überleitung gewesen. Aber ganz kalt aus der Hüfte.
Linus, du bist ein Fuchs, ein Podcast Fuchs,
Denn äh weitere Gefährdungen sind äh bekannt geworden,
Derzeit ist es ja so, dass Julia Reeder einzige verbliebene Piratin im EU-Parlament. Jetzt seit der letzten Legislaturperiode mit
dabei, dass sie äh sicher extrem engagiert,
in äh ja in dem Projekt Novelle des Urheberrechts. Sie möchte das vorantreiben und treibt es auch voran und zwar nicht nur mit klugen Vorschlägen, sondern auch,
Da kommt der Finger von Linos.
Wollte nur kurz darauf hinweisen, dass es natürlich nicht eine Novelle des Urheberrechts ist, sondern eine Vereinheitlichung und Harmonisierung des.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, die haben Munition des Binnenmarktes. Äh,
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Ich wollte jetzt mal ein bisschen romatisieren, aber das ist dann gleich wieder äh auf der Strecke geblieben. Also ich äh hebe nochmal an. Äh weitere Harmonisierung. Es ist ja auch ein schönes Wort, ne? Harmonisierung.
Ist doch schön, Harmonie.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir unseren Podcast nochmal ein bisschen harmonisieren.
Nicht mehr Europäische Union, sondern europäische Harmonie.
Genau. Soll ich nochmal anfangen? Auf jeden Fall,
Ist da extrem engagiert und sie wurde ja auch zur Berichterstatterin für äh diese Initiative ähm,
bestellt. Zuständig ist der Rechtsausschuss im Parlament und das hat jetzt auch erste,
Ergebnisse erzielt. Das heißt, es gab eine Abstimmung im äh Rechtsausschuss, wo eine ganze Reihe von.
Vorschlägen, die wohl auch in Julias Originalpapier so drin standen, welches wie ich zugeben muss, ich nicht gelesen habe, sondern nur berichte darüber. Ähm da wurde auch einiges von,
aber nicht alles. Und so kommt es, dass eben jetzt in dieser ganzen Debatte eine Harmonisierung.
Urheberrechts, auch die ein oder andere Verschlechterung hier mit äh hereinkommen. Und konkret betrifft das jetzt vor allem, nicht nur die Panoramafreiheit.
Panoramafreiheit, die wir äh,
gerade schon so schön beschrieben hat, ist ja sozusagen eine Einschränkung des Urheberrechts, von der es ja nicht so viele gibt.
Ein sehr,
starkes Urheberrecht in äh Europa, was wirklich wenig, wenig Ausnahmen hat, äh eine Ausnahme ist zum Beispiel das Zitatrecht, ja, also wenn man quasi jetzt so in der Zeitung äh irgendwas,
oder auch bleiben wir beim Radio, ja, wenn man im Radio dann irgendwie ein äh Werk äh anspielt und man
kann aber nachweisen, dass man jetzt hier wirklich zitiert und es sind bestimmte Länge nicht überschreitet et cetera et cetera PP. Dann äh darf man das. Äh und halt auch die Panoramafrei, die im Prinzip sagt, wenn du draußen Foto machst, dann äh,
Ist es egal, was da rumsteht und selbst wenn das Werk irgendwie urheberrechtlich geschützt ist, steht halt einfach in der Öffentlichkeit rum und wie willst du da dein Selfie machen, wenn da irgendwie äh der Eiffelturm äh,
dann steht er da halt und dann ist er halt auch mit auf dem Bild,
Tatsächlich ist hier auch, also gerade, was die Panoramafreiheit betrifft, ein enormer Harmonisierungsbedarf auch vorhanden. Die äh Gesetzgebungen sind in Europa teilweise sehr unterschiedlich.
Äh wie mir gewahr wurde, scheint wohl die liberalste äh Anwendung tatsächlich in Österreich vorzuherrschen, wo es wohl knipsen kannst, wie äh nix Gutes, so. Andere Länder sehen das anders, zum Beispiel Frankreich
Und ja, die äh Änderungen, die jetzt hier diskutiert wird, würde aber diese Panoramafreiheit weiter einschränken, weil ja hier gesagt wird, na ja
ähm,
wenn hier gewerbliche Absichten äh existieren, dann äh müssten halt wieder mal alle Rechteinhaber befragt werden, was natürlich irgendwie Quatsch ist, weil was was weiß ich, wenn ich draußen fotografiere, was ich da alles mitnehmen
ne? Und wir wissen auch, auf was sich das beziehen kann, ja? Also Kunstwerke, Gebäude,
Ja, also es gibt ja immer diese absurde Situation, Gebäude dürfen nicht verändert werden, wenn der Urheber sozusagen da äh Veränderungen verhindern möchte. Da hatten wir die Debatte mit dem Bahnhof et cetera,
generell mit öffentlichen Gebäuden.
Ich erinnere mich da sofort an Google.
War das da auch ein Thema? Ja, wahrscheinlich, ne?
Verpixelte Häuser.
Aber das war doch nicht über das Urheberrecht.
Ach, das war über Datenschutz, ne? Aber das würde ja dann sicherlich da auch.
Ja, das äh interessante Frage, ne. Äh auf jeden Fall gibt's da Widerstand und äh der Widerstand hat sich jetzt am stärksten und am schnellsten gezeigt, bei der Wikipedia, die das natürlich äh verständlicherweise nicht so äh witzig findet.
Und da am neunten Juli schon im Parlament darüber abgestimmt werden soll,
gibt's jetzt einen offenen Brief, der Wikipedianer, der deutschen Wikipedia-Community
noch bis zum neunundzwanzigsten Juni online auch da mitunterschrieben werden kann von der Community, wo sie halt sagen, so dass es ihnen halt mit dieser neuen Regelung einfach nicht mehr möglich sei, Fotos aus dem öffentlichen Raum,
unter freien Lizenzen zu veröffentlichen, äh da halt auch Wikipedia sämtliche Bilder in einer Form lizensiert sind, die auch äh eine gewerbliche Weiternutzung äh zulässt und das äh,
unter anderem auch bedeuten, dass gegebenenfalls existierende Bilder,
gelöscht werden müssen und das wäre halt alles äh nicht vereinbar mit ihren Zielen äh hat hier eine Wissensarmende äh aufzubauen, zumal eben,
hier auch keinen äh zu rechtfertigender Nutzen gegenüber steht. Und dementsprechend möchte man sich dort ans Parlament wenden, um diese Einschränkungen äh entsprechend.
Ja, zu verhindern, ne?
Will jetzt hier nicht so auf die weiteren Details dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsnovelle eingehen. Dazu habe ich mich da A zu wenig zu beschäftigt und b ähm,
wenig zu sagen. Äh es gibt wohl noch so,
weitere Kritikpunkte daran, einerseits, dass halt äh hier nicht wirklich irgendwas in Richtung FairUse, wie das in den USA zum Beispiel existiert, äh etabliert wird, es gibt auch keine,
entsprechende Ausdehnung dieses Zitatrechts, was ja auch gefordert wurde, wer auch mal für Podcasts äh ganz nett und von Harmonisierung kann wohl durch die schwammige Formulierung, äh die dort gewählt werden beim Urheberrecht eigentlich auch nicht wirklich die Rede sein,
Und außerdem gibt's auch noch so ein paar unklare Aussagen äh zu Data Mining, ja
und zwar unklar einerseits, weil halt hier von vorneherein von irgendwelchen Ausnahmen gesprochen wird und na ja, aber wenn's um Forschung geht und so weiter, dann kann man das ja machen, wobei sich halt einige Leute fragen so, äh Moment, hier äh Daten und Urheberrecht, äh wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Also da gibt's auf jeden Fall noch den einen oder anderen Blick äh zu werfen auf diese ganzen Prozesse,
ganz nett, wenn man hier vielleicht mal Julia irgendwie äh zu dem Thema mal selber vielleicht an Start bekommen könnten, aber die ist natürlich auch enorm unterwegs.
Ja, so viel dazu. Und dauert auch noch irgendwie was mit Cyber.
Cyber, ja. Ähm wir haben ja die Situation der,
Der Vermittlung des Kenntnisstandes über den Trojanerangriff auf den deutschen Bundestag zu Genüge kritisiert.
Und ähm und dann am Ende einfach mal,
ohne ähm direkten Bezug halt äh da ein bisschen Informationen zu vermitteln, wie denn sowas in der Regel abläuft und gerade in der letzten Sendung habe ich da ja,
ein ganz interessanten Informanten noch zu gefunden,
die Linksfraktion im Bundestag hat äh Claudio Guarni äh bestellt, um sich mal einen ihrer Rechner anzuschauen. Der ähm.
Ist den verorte ich so in der beim Citizen Lab. Da bin ich zum Beispiel zum ersten Mal über auf ihn aufmerksam geworden. Er hat vor einiger Zeit, da haben wir auch drüber gesprochen, diesen ähm,
ja, dieses Antivirus Tool für Staatstrojaner veröffentlicht,
namens da eher über das Citizen Lab natürlich Zugang zu mehreren.
Ähm Staatstrojaner, Varianten hatte und eben für die, die erkannte, eben dann ein ein Detektionstour geschrieben hat und äh beschäftigt sich seit einiger Zeit eingehend,
tiefgehend mit mit und er hat also denen dann ein Analyse.
Ergebnis geliefert hat einen Analysebericht geliefert.
Der dann auch bei Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht wurde. Ähm jetzt hat er also auf diesen Rechnern tatsächlich ähm zwei Sachen gefunden.
Die zusammengehören, er nennt das Artifakt eins und Artifakt zwei. Das ist im Prinzip das,
so grob übersetzt, was ich in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt habe, dass es eben so einmal diesen Einschleuser gibt und dann den den eigentlichen Trojaner so ungefähr ist auch die ähm Arbeitsteilung zwischen,
diesen beiden Artifakten,
auch, was ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon so geschildert habe, dass man sich eben in den in den Bootprozess ähm versteckt. Ähm,
und oder als System Dienst oder Systemservices tarnt, insbesondere ist das hier äh die
SVC Host dot echse, die es auf jedem Windows Rechner mindestens seit irgendwie wahrscheinlich neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig gibt, weil ähm,
zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich mich schon irgendwie über diese über dieses Ding im Task Manager aufgeregt
und irgendwie versucht zu googeln, was das Ding überhaupt macht. Also dieser Prozess läuft auf jeden Windows-System. Hier dann in Form einer Datei, die SVC Haus, dort Excel dot extra heißt. Ähm.
Er ähm hat die also im Rahmen einer dynamischen Analyse äh untersucht,
Wie ich das hier sehe oder auch eine teilweise,
Statische Analyse, ja, sieht auch nach statischer Analyse aus. Statisch heißt, ähm, ich versuche, den Code zu reversen und zu sehen, was, was, was finden sich da für Funktionen drin? Dynamisch heißt, ich führe das aus und in einer,
Umgebung, die ich kontrolliere, virtuelle Maschinen oder so und versuche, zu erkennen, was denn diese.
Datei tut. Und ähm hat dann so aller aller mögliche Einzel,
Analysen, darüber gefahren, die jetzt denke ich mal, für die politische Untersuchung eher unerheblich sind und auch,
nur für den Interessierten oder die interessierte Leserin, wirklich eine Rolle spielen und sagt dann, ja, dieses Artefakt zwei,
namens SVC Horst Excel dot exe verbindet sich zu der IP-Adresse eins sieben sechs Punkt drei eins Punkt eins eins zwei Punkt eins null. Und diese IP-Adresse ist bekannt
ja? Denn sie kommen in vorherigen Analysen.
Der Firma, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, vor die äh Berichte über Myware veröffentlicht hat und dieser Myware ähm.
Einen Namen gegeben hat, APT achtundzwanzig. Es hat irgendwann angefangen, also sie haben irgendwann angefangen so,
Staatstrojaner oder besonders krasse Angreifer als APTs zu bezeichnen in den letzten Jahren. Advanced Persisten
Also ein fortgeschrittener Angreifer mit besonderen Fähigkeiten, der persistent ist, also nicht aufgibt,
Wenn er beim ersten Mal scheitert und ähm diesem,
Dieser Angreifer, Gruppe oder diesen Feining wurden mehrere Namen gegeben, einmal,
Group, APT achtundzwanzig oder Operation Poinstone. Ähm.
Und denen wurde halt in unterschiedlichen ähm.
Denen wurden unterschiedliche Angriffe zugeordnet, wo sich dann wieder eines der äh,
Subsysteme zu dieser IP-Adresse verbunden hat. Ähm unter der IP-Adresse selber ist dann irgendwie so ein irgendwie so ein Web-Mail-Oberfläche,
um eben einfach möglichst,
unauffällig zu sein. Ne, also das ist natürlich was naheliegendes, dass du halt irgend so eine Standard irgendwie eine Outlook äh oder eine eine Roundcube oder irgendwie so eine Oberfläche, die man halt überall kennt. Äh unter der IP-Adresse,
ähm laufen lässt und damit halt, wenn jemand vorbeikommt, dass das irgendwie halbwegs äh vernünftig aussieht. Ähm,
Adresse selber ist irgendwie beinahe französischen Firma zugeordnet aber wahrscheinlich in Pakistan weiß der Geier aber da muss ich auch sagen da sind halt die.
Ähm die Analysen jetzt auch nicht so ähm.
So wahnsinnig schlauer als das, was man halt irgendwie herausfinden kann, wenn man halt ein bisschen guckt, geo IP Lookups macht und ähm halt nach der IP-Adresse googelt und dann eben feststellt, dass es da,
dass die einschlägig bekannt ist. Ob das jetzt tatsächlich,
Russland zugeordnet werden kann anhand dieser IP-Adresse. Daran scheiden sich natürlich die Geister. Man kann natürlich einmal.
Den Verweis auf frühere Zuordnungen machen, man kann aber natürlich auch ähm darauf blicken, in welchem,
Politischen Großrahmen diese ähm.
Vorherigen bekannten Angriffe stattgefunden haben, auf technischer Ebene ist das natürlich immer relativ,
schwierig, da so 'ne Atribution vorzunehmen und.
Hast du ja auch letztes Mal schon erläutert, wie schwierig das ist.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Nicht ganz sicher sein kann.
Ich glaube auch, dass Claudio selber das eben auch äh also er formuliert das innerhalb der äh.
Security-Community besteht weitgehende Einigkeit darüber, dass das wahrscheinlich Russland ist. Ja? Was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, dass er ähm nicht das berichtet,
oder ich hab's nicht ausreichend gut gelesen, aber dass er eben nicht berichtet, dass da eben dieses mywethr kit ähm Minicuts,
die an der ähm an dem Mensch, der erstellt dieser beiden, wie es beteiligt zu gewesen zu sein scheint. Und das gibt dann nochmal den vorsichtigen.
Vorsichtigen Zweifel, ja, den ich jetzt hier an dieser Stelle nicht formulieren möchte, ich sage nur, dass eben andere behauptet haben,
und vor allem diese Firma, die im Bundestag jetzt da offiziell beauftragt ist, dass da eventuell Minicuts eine Rolle gespielt habe, beziehungsweise das lesen wir in anderen Medien,
Und jetzt ist eben auch nicht auszuschließen,
dass der Claudio einen anderen Trojaner analysiert hat. Das wäre dann aber nicht seine Schuld, sondern das wäre dann das Problem der ähm eben nicht,
wirklich umfassenden Berichterstattung, die wir aus diesem Bereich bisher bekommen. Insofern ist das natürlich sehr schön, dass er die Gelegenheit zu dieser Analyse hatte,
und diese Analyse ist auch sehr erkenntnisreich für jemanden, der sich mit ähm,
Mit Myware auseinandersetzt. Für die politische Zuordnung.
Denke ich, ähm sind diese Ergebnisse erstmal noch mit Vorsicht zu behandeln.
Andererseits ist es natürlich schon durchaus interessant, wenn ähm.
Was mich zum Beispiel wirklich überrascht, dass ernsthaft die über mehrere.
Jahre und mehrere Entdeckungen hinweg immer noch die gleiche IP-Adresse benutzen,
Ich meine, du kriegst nichts so leicht, wie eine andere IP. Okay,
Klammer auf, die IP V vier Adressen werden langsam rar äh in Amerika sind's jetzt glaube ich in Nordamerika sind jetzt bald alle ausverkauft,
aber auch immer wieder neu besungen, insbesondere in so Podcasts voller Freaks, die den ganzen Tag nur von sechs reden.
Das sind die schlimmsten.
Das sind die schlimmsten, ja, aber ähm es ist jetzt nicht so, dass IP vor vier so rar ist, dass du deinen dämlichen Kommanden-Controll-Server nicht mal irgendwie mit was anderem mit einer anderen IP-Adresse ausstatten kannst. Interessant,
Also interessante Artikel oder interessanter Bericht, den ich äh zu lesen hier empfehle.
Dann auch noch um andere IP-Adressen, die dann eben bei der äh Zuordnung auch nochmal eine Rolle spielen. Ähm.
Aber für die Attribution sind wir da jetzt, glaube ich, nicht wirklich weitergekommen.
Dann gab's noch eine äh Berichterstattung jetzt glaube ich heute oder gestern, wo es um,
die Sicherheit von Bundestag DE beziehungsweise von Bundestag DE geht, der Christian Köntop hat da mal irgendwie.
In dem IP-Adressbereich äh ein bisschen rumgescannt und hat festgestellt, dass wenn er die IPs oder wenn er IPs in dem Bereich Bundestag DE ähm.
Anspricht, auf HTTPS,
ohne sie über den Domainnamen anzusprechen, dass sie dann teilweise komische ähm Domainnamen in den Zertifikaten haben. Und diese Domainnamen,
hatten ähm komische Änderungen, die es nicht als wirkliche Top-Level Domains gibt. So was wie Punkt frag. Und hat daraus den ähm.
Frack. Ja. So wie das Kleidungsstück.
FRK, FRAK, also Fraktion oder so. Ähm und hat daraus den sehr nahe liegenden äh Verdacht bekommen, dass es sich dabei um Server handelt, die,
Nicht nur im Internet Exposts sind, sondern die gleichzeitig auch im Intranet des Bundestages äh Dienste anbieten.
Über zwei Interfaces äh genau. Oh Mann.
Und
Ähm ich, also er hat diese Analyse vollständig äh durchgeführt. Hat noch andere Sachen gefunden, komme ich gleich zu, ich wurde dann von ähm der Süddeutschen Zeitung mit den Ergebnissen konfrontiert und wurde gebeten, da auch nochmal
ähm einfach die Schwere des Vergehens.
Ähm zu beurteilen. Wenn du jetzt also einen Server hast, der,
Einmal im öffentlichen Internetdienste anbietet und auch in einem Intranet. Dann hast du natürlich das Problem,
dass wenn jetzt jemand aus dem Internet diesen Server übernimmt, er dann,
Diesen Server als Ausgangsposition in einem Intranet hat. Und von da aus dann eben auch
ein Fuß in diesem internen Netz. Ähm deswegen es bietet oder empfiehlt es sich im Prinzip ein ein Intranet, was man ja eigentlich nur aus dem Grunde anlegt, dass man irgendetwas hat,
in diesem Netz, was man nicht im Internet haben möchte. Das ist der Grund, warum überhaupt ein Intranet macht. Ähm.
Und wenn du jetzt irgendetwas davon öffentlich Expost, dann hast du quasi etwas, was man, wenn man das haben möchte,
ein Jump-Post nennt, also ein Horst, wo du dich hinnecken kannst, von dem aus du dann weiterspringen kannst in das internen, in das Intranetz, in das interne Netz. Das wäre natürlich äußerst unglücklich, wenn,
Das tatsächlich der Fall ist. Und das, was äh Christian Köntop da gefunden hat, ähm lässt eigentlich.
Kaum einen anderen Schluss zu. Der beste,
Beste und die wohlwollendste Interpretation wäre, dass sie eventuell.
Die Hosts zwar getrennt haben, aber irgendwie kopiert haben, ja, also.
Zertifikate, die überall dieselbe Konfiguration haben.
Keine saubere Trennung zwischen irgendwie internen Systemen, externen Systemen, Entwicklungssystemen, Systemen oder sowas haben,
wenn man dann aber sich noch weiter umschaut in den Sachen, die er so gefunden hat. Er hat da offenbar mal so einen Cross Side Scripting,
Äh scannen lassen, über ein paar Domains, Subtomans, die auch sich im Bundestag also in dem Bereich, in dem Bundestag DE bewegen,
und hatte auch noch einige Cross-Side-Scripting ähm Schwächen gefunden. Crossside Scripting.
Bedeutet, ähm ich versuche, ich versuche das jetzt mal wieder einfach zu erklären. Ähm.
Erinnere mich bitte gleich daran, dass ich noch einen Fehler aus der letzten Sendung korrigieren muss, aber erst erkläre ich jetzt erst versuche ich jetzt nochmal, was einfach zu erklären. Man stelle sich vor,
Ein Suchfeld, ja? Und bei zum Beispiel auf Logbuch Netzpolitik DE gibt's eine Suche. Und jetzt schreibe ich da rein, ähm,
Ich suche nach Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja? Dann wird, dann kommt eine Seite, in der steht ihre Suche nach Vorratsdatenspeicherung, lieferte folgende Ergebnisse und dann steht da drunter, was weiß ich.
Meinten sie, Regierungsfähigkeit.
Nein, dann steht da drunter LMP hundertdreiundvierzig, LMP hundertzweiundvierzig, LMP hunderteinundvierzig und so weiter, ja.
So und jetzt könnte man sich vorstellen, dass ich da reinschreibe,
Ich möchte suchen nach spitze Klammer auf, Skript, Typ, gleich Java Skript und dann ein Java Skript dahinschreibe und dann,
Würde eine Seite,
sich dem Nutzer offenbaren, wo steht ihre Suche nach Doppelpunkt. Da steht dann gar nichts, lieferte folgende Ergebnisse und dann sich quasi in dieser Seite mein Java Skript befindet.
Und diese Java Skript, der Browser dann nimmt und denkt, ach, ein Jar, es gibt, führe ich jetzt mal aus. Und,
jetzt könnte man natürlich als Angreifer mit diesen Javas gibt allen möglichen Mist machen.
Unter anderem, man könnte halt an komplett andere Seiten darstellen, man könnte Passwörter klauen, man könnte ähm,
um sich aus der Position des Opfers heraus in einem anderen Netz bewegen und so weiter. Man kann da relativ viel machen. Crossside Scripting ist in der Regel aber erst dann interessant,
wenn das eingegebene Skript dann auch unter einer, in einer anderen Situation wieder möglichst jemand anderem angezeigt wird,
Also gehen wir von der Suchseite weg und sagen, wir hätten jetzt die Möglichkeit, Skripts einzufügen in den Kommentaren von Logbuch Netz,
also kommentiere sowieso versucht das ruhig ich glaub die Lücke die Wordpress da irgendwie vor drei Wochen hatte, ist jetzt geschlossen
hoffentlich auch bei Tim. Ansonsten haben wir jetzt ein Problem. Da könnte man also ein Skript schreiben, was zum Beispiel den Inhalt der Seite ändert, ne, oder irgendwelche oder dann sagt, geben sie ihr Passwort ein oder sonst was. Und das ist natürlich dann relativ kritisch, weil man mit diesem Skript dann auch den
Inhalt der Seite wieder auslesen könnte. Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt kommen wir in den Bereich der Fantasie.
Ähm einem SPD oder einem einem Bundestagsabgeordneten einen Link schicken, ihn dazu bringen, darauf zu klicken. Dies wäre ein interner Link,
auf so eine Intranetseite und in dem Anschluss an diesen Link findet sich dann ein Java Skript, welches zu ich ihn dann.
Welches er dann ausführen wird und dieses findet dann eben interne Inhalte, die ihm angezeigt werden. Das ist jetzt wirklich ein sehr theoretischer Angriff. Der,
Dadurch erschwert wird, dass sich das Skript in im Prinzip immer wieder mit in den Link einbauen muss. Das heißt, die tatsächliche Verwundbarkeit, die,
jetzt hier gefunden wurde, ist erstmal nicht so dramatisch, weil das Skript, was jemand eingibt, eben nicht jemand anderem angezeigt wird, sondern immer quasi mit in den Link rein muss. Ist aber trotzdem eine potentielle Angriffsmöglichkeit,
nicht besonders kritisch. Nach meiner Bewertung auch relativ selten gesehen.
In der freien Wildbahn vor allem in dieser Form, aber ein ähm.
Ein eine Angriffsmöglichkeit oder eine Schwäche, die mir vor allem deshalb Sorgen macht, weil man sie automatisch findet. Und wenn du oder automatisch finden kann und wenn du,
in dieser Web TV Seite vom Deutschen Bundestag, Sicherheits,
Lücken hast, die du im Prinzip mit einem Scanner finden kannst, dann heißt das, dass diese Seite nicht.
Eingehend und vor allem nicht kompetent auf Sicherheit geprüft wurde.
Weil so was darf dir nicht passieren, dass du ein Cross-Side Scripting hast.
Das ist einfach, das ist einfach schlechter Stil. So, das das ist einfach, das das gibt es halt. Das hast du halt nicht so. Das passiert,
Im komplexeren Bereich dann immer mal wieder,
Vor allem, wenn du anfängst, Kommentare abzuschneiden oder so, das war, glaube ich, dann auch die Schwäche bei Wordpress. Dass äh Wordpress die Kommentare auf fünftausend Zeichen beschränkt hat und das wiederum
es dem Angreifer ermöglicht hat, ein Skript zu schreiben, was dann letztendlich von Wordpress irgendwie abgeschnitten wird und dann doch wieder ausgeführt wird. Ähm.
Aber diese.
Kommt vollständig auszuräumen ist wirklich sehr schwierig. Gibt's auch einige Sicherheitsforscher, die da äh sehr interessante Ergebnisse immer und immer wieder präsentieren. Aber das, was da gefunden wurde, war eher ähm,
ähm Einsteigerniveau.
Also im Prinzip haben wir jetzt zwei Sachen besprochen, diese Dual-Home-Sache und diese Croissants-Sache, ich meine äh unabhängig davon, wie verwundbar das ist, ist auf jeden Fall vermeidbar,
und dann ist es nicht mehr da.
Und dieser Fall von war äh sehr, sehr einfach zu finden.
Genau, aber die andere Geschichte das also was wir jetzt nicht beweisen können, aber du meinst, du hast dir das genauer angeschaut und das es scheint zumindest nichts unwahrscheinlich zu.
Also entweder sie haben, sie haben zwei, zwei, die Welle, also sie entwickeln beides auf einer Plattform und pushen es dann einmal.
Also im besten Fall weiß es äh genau, im besten Fall weißt du's auf schlechte Administrative
Praktiken hin. Im äh schlimmsten Fall weist es tatsächlich auf so eine Situation hin, wo du quasi äh äh in den Empfangs äh Bereich eines Krankenhauses reingehst und da ist dann noch so eine Tür und du fragst dich, was ist denn das eigentlich für eine Tür? Du machst die auf, du stehst im OP-Saal so,
äh wo man einfach mal nicht äh hinkommen sollte, weil da eigentlich äh so ein bisschen so German,
German Control sozusagen äh ja, passieren sollte. Und das ist schon.
Also wer es schafft, diese Server zu übernehmen.
Also ohnehin hat man jetzt schon Kenntnisse auf, also eins haben wir auf jeden Fall, Kenntnisse über die interne Namensauflösung im äh internen Netz des deutschen Bundestages. Wir können weiterhin,
Davon ausgehen, dass das, was wir auf dem öffentlichen Server finden, mindestens das Gleiche ist,
Was man auch auf dem internen Server finden kann. Das heißt, eine du könntest also Schwachstellen, die du in dem einen hast, auch in dem anderen ähm vermuten und dann eben quasi ein,
Ein Cross-Size-Scripting-Angriff oder ein Skript-Injection-Angriff,
Auf jemanden machen, der sich in dem internen Netz befindet. Und wenn es, wenn das naheliegende wahr ist, dann könntest du von außen den einen Server übernehmen und wärst dann halt in dem Internet drin.
Und das ähm darf man nicht. Da gibt's halt äh klare Designprinzipien, die einem solche Entscheidungen ähm abnehmen, indem sie einfach sagen, du sollst nicht.
Ein Server, der in einem internen Netz ist, gleichzeitig im im freien Internetexposen, weil ist schlecht.
Du sollst nicht Dual Homan.
Na du kannst schon Dual Home, aber du sollst aber nicht, wenn wenn die an einem der beiden Netze was liegt.
Ja, das kann man schon machen, aber das ist halt scheiße.
So, jetzt steht er noch.
Was war der Fehler? Es alle wissen.
Das heißt, auf einigen dieser Dienste, die unter Bundestag DE laufen, ähm gibt es Anhaltspunkte für also nicht unter
Direktbundestag DE, da gab's nämlich dann noch eine äh Gegendarstellung bei äh bei der Süddeutschen, wo nämlich jemand sagte, Bundestag DE im Sinne von WWW Bundestag DE äh betreibt äh jemand anderes.
Und die IP-Auft Adressen, auf die sich diese Untersuchung jetzt beziehen, sind nicht diejenigen, die Bundestag DE machen, sondern sowas wie WebTV Punkt Bundestag DE. Ähm.
Aber man findet da also zumindest schon Anhaltspunkte für sehr unsaubere und nicht besonders Security bewusste Arbeit.
Jetzt wollte ich noch kurz meinen Fehler in der letzten Sendung aufklären. Äh du hast mich da ja nervös gemacht, als ich das X-Or erklärt habe, das X-Or steht für exklusives oder das heißt, das Ausschließende oder.
Und ich habe, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung gesagt, dass das X-Or eins wird, wenn die Zahlen,
Sind und null wird, wenn sie falsch sind, aber es ist natürlich genau andersrum das X-Ohr wird,
eins, wenn die Zahlen unterschiedlich sind, deswegen heißt es ja auch exklusives oder denn dann ist das exklusive oder war und war es eins.
So sieht's aus. Die Wahrheit hier live bei wir haben sie endlich geklärt. Die Antwort lautet eins.
Die exklusive Antwort lautet eins oder.
Oder wie Holland, den du vorhin ja schon äh aufgeschworen hast, mal so schön gesagt hat, alles ist eins. Außer der Null.
Ciao. Äh.
Über zwei Stunden sind wir jetzt bald.
Ja, aber wir haben noch eine noch eine vermeintlich gute Nachricht zum Schluss. Die die könnte noch lustig werden.
Ja gut.
Äh kam nämlich gerade rein über den Ticker. Ja, wir haben ja hier so ein Fax-Gerät, wie so so ein Teletype, so ein so ein.
Ich dachte, hier kam so ein Ticker rein.
Telex. Hey, hast du, hast du was tickert? Äh und zwar hat das äh Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig,
ein äh Urteil oder ein Urteil gefällt, ein ja, zumindest eine eine Entscheidung äh herbeigeführt. Das nennt man dann wahrscheinlich Urteil.
Äh zu der Fragestellung, äh was denn nun mit diesen Ausarbeitungen des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestags ist. Ja, also äh der Bundestag hat ja da so,
Wissenschaftler oder zumindest ein wissenschaftlichen Dienst, der unter anderem mit vielen Wissenschaftlern bestückt sein sollte.
Sind die, die für den, die für den Gutenberg die Doktorarbeit geschrieben.
Genau, das sind die, die für die Gutenberg die äh Doktorarbeit geschrieben haben.
Nenne ich mal einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst.
Ja, genau, die aber auch ab und zu mal so Bewertungen machen, wie denn das nun so ist mit der Rechtslage und das sind hier was irgendwie verfassungskonform und ist dann irgendwas äh so rechtens und äh in die richtige Richtung gedacht. Das ist quasi so eine Dienstleistung
Bundestagsabgeordnete nicht nur Bundestagsabgeordnete aber vor allem Bundestagsabgeordnete die dann einfach mal irgendwas auf,
Wahrheitsgehalt oder zumindest auf ihre wissenschaftlichen Position hin,
abgeklopft werden können. Tolle Sache, hätte ich auch gern, so einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst, ja, also ich meine.
Wir haben so gewisse Kreise, die uns so äh umgeistern, die eine ähnliche Funktion äh haben. Äh na ja, so und der Streitpunkt war,
sind diese Arbeiten des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes äh Teil der Verwaltung.
Oder sind sie Teil der Arbeit des jeweiligen Mandatsträgers, der diesen wissenschaftlichen Dienst beauftragt oder anders ausgedrückt, ist das, was er äh äh in Auftrag gegeben hat,
Was hat er immer für sich schreiben lassen sollte? Äh lässt sich das mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz abfragen oder nicht? Und,
Bundesverwaltungsgericht meint,
Ist mal ganz klar, Verwaltung hier und wenn's Verwaltung ist, dann ist es auch vom IFG abgedeckt. Mit anderen Worten, das könnte jetzt heißen, dass demnächst IFG-Anfragen nach solchen Dokumenten durchkommen müssten,
Äh nur haben wir natürlich hier mal wieder äh,
Urheberrechts äh Belange, die dann äh mit mit reinkommen, also die zumindest ja immer wieder vorangeschoben werden mit so, na ja, wir würden's ihnen ja gerne sagen, aber äh da ist ja Urheberrecht drauf und so weiter. Wir hatten da diese,
da mit dem äh Innenministerium et cetera äh jüngst, von daher muss man mal abwarten, was äh kommt. Aber äh könnte unter Umständen noch ein paar lustige Informationsfreiheitsanfragen äh geben. Ich schätze mal, bei äh Netzpolitik Punkt org hat
man äh schon mal wieder die Maus geschärft, um dann mal ganz treffsicher äh aufwacht den Staat, ein paar passende.
Die Studie zu den Ufos.
Alle Studien, die äh Gutenberg in Auftrag gegeben hat. Was meinst du, was dann mit dem guten Plug los ist? Was jetzt irgendwie vierundachtzig Prozent.
Ja, das könnte spannend werden.
Ja, da haben wir dann nochmal eine eine schöne Nachricht gehabt. Mensch.
Genau. Mensch.
Haben wir sonst noch was? Haben wir sonst noch was anzukündigen, zu sagen zu.
Äh nicht so nicht so direkt, glaube ich. Also wir haben wir rollen gerade die eine oder andere äh Idee für die nächste Zeit, aber das alles noch nicht spruchfähig. Und ähm ja, insofern.
Noch ein paar Dankeschöns verteilen.
Ja, danke schön geht an dieser Woche ich weiß denn heute mit mir los?
Du bist müde, es ist.
Ich bin echt müde. Ist es am frühen Morgen.
Wohl es noch so früh am Morgen ist, ist es schon recht spät.
Ja ich ähm ich danke, dass dank der Dank gilt Kostia und Philipp.
Und da ist er bestimmt gut auf.
Und das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass ich gerade Sprachfindungsschwierigkeiten habe.
Na ja, nach so einem zwei Stunden Klopper, da kann man auch mal ein bisschen aus der Spur geraten. Wir sagen äh tschüss und äh bis bald, liebe Zuhörer, kommt zahlreich wieder zu uns, empfehlt uns weiter,
und äh bis nächste Woche.
Bis nächste Woche.
Tschüss.